bonjour à tous une femme meurt tous les
2 jours sous les cous de son compagnon
c'est pour renforcer la lutte contre les
violences conjugales que le Sénat
examine une proposition de loi sur le
sujet de mesures innovantes la création
d'un délit de violence pscologique
désormais le fait de harceler son
conjoint sera passible de 5 ans de
prison autre mesure l'ordonnance de
protection des victimes le juge des
affaires familiales pourra protéger une
femme menacée de coup il pourra
notamment ordonner l'évictions du
conjoint du domicile conjugal ce texte
est défendu à la fois par la droite et
par la gauche tout de suite direction
l'hémicycle poursivre la discussion
générale très bonne
séance la parole est à notre collègue
Odette terade pour le groupe crcspg pour
15 minutes mon chers collègues vous avez
la parole en terme élégant ces choseslà
sont bien dites monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues enfin mot de
circonstance mes chers collègues au
regard du temps écoulé et des 16000
pétitions signées pour que ce texte soit
débattu à l'Assemblée nationale et
arrive enfin jusqu'à nous déjà en 2006
notre groupe avec la PPL déposée par
notre présidente Nicole borveau avait
largement contribué avec la la
proposition de loi notre collègue
Courteau à ce qui est devenu la première
pierre de la reconnaissance des
violences faites aux femmes
ensuite en 2007 nous avons relayé et
déposé la proposition de loi cadre des
associations féministes de lutte contre
les violences à l'encontre des femmes
fruit d'un long travail de concertation
et de réflexion avec les magistrats les
associés
ou collectif de femmes fruit aussi de
l'expérience du seul observatoire des
violences envers les femmes existants en
France celui du Conseil Général de la
saintesinen la proposition de loi que
nous examinons ce soir n'est pas une
conclusion mais plutôt une maturation et
marque une nouvelle étape importante
pour les droits des femmes une étape
pour laquelle nous nous devons de
répondre présente et présent tant les
attentes des victimes sont fortes le
crime conjugal reste encore défini par
notre société comme un crime passionnel
et les violences contre les femmes ne
sont des circonstances aggravantes que
depuis les textes de 2006 en la matière
le constat est alarmant une femme sur 10
victime de violence dans son couple soit
1800000 femmes par an c'est énorme parmi
elles un tiers est victime de violence
grave et très grave selon une enquête de
Linse publiée en 2007 200000 femmes sont
victimes de viol par an une femme meurt
assassinée par son son compagnon son
ex-compagnon tous les de jours au-delà
de l'effroyable énoncée de ces chiffres
nous avons encore une marge de progrès
certaine dans le domaine de statistique
fiable d'ailleurs le rapport de notre
collègue François Pillet indique que les
chiffres constatés par les services de
police et de gendarmerie paraissent bien
en DEA des violences subies selon
l'Observatoire national de la
délinquence on le nombre de plaintes
déposées par les victimes de violence
conjugale représenterait moins de 9 %
des violences conjugales réellement
subies ainsi je peux vous dire selon ces
statistiques de ce même observatoire
national de la délinquence qu'il y a
400000 voitures volées par an mais je
suis incapable de vous dire combien il y
a de femmes mutilées ou infirm à vie ou
combien sont défénestrés ou suicidés du
fait des violences dans le couple au fur
et à mesure où les statistiques
s'affinent les chiffres augmentent et on
découvre davantage les ravages que font
ces violences faites aux femmes sur
toute la société
des chiffres justes et précis n'existent
que si un travail spécifique est engagé
pour l'année 2010 les violence faite aux
femmes ont été déclaré grande cause
nationale il est donc urgent de cerner
au plus près la situation pour y
remédier selon l'enquête européenne
d'aphné c'est plus d'une femme par jour
qui dans notre pays aujourd'hui serait
tué tué par son conjoint ou son
ex-conjoint ainsi quand un phénomène
atteint une telle proportion d'individus
il il s'agit d'un véritable phénomène de
société qui concerne bien la société
toute entière les comportements violents
des hommes envers les femmes sont des
actes individuels inscrits dans des
rapports sociaux de domination masculine
encore trop fortement tolérés par notre
société il n'est pas rare que l'on parle
de différents au sein des couples pour
ne pas nommer pour ne pas avoir à nommer
le mot violence mes chers collègues de
fortes résistance au changement fondé
sur les discriminations entre les femmes
femmes et les hommes persistent dans
notre société c'est pourquoi je soutiens
l'intitulé de cette proposition de loi
qui indique clairement qu'il existe dans
notre société des violences spécifiques
faites aux femmes permettez-moi d'avoir
une pensée pour toutes celles qui
souffrent de ces violences pour toutes
celles qui résistent et cherchent de
l'aide une pensée pour les enfants
témoins privilégiés de ces violences et
une pensée aussi pour les professionnels
et les associations qui les accompagnent
l'expérience des avocats ou des
associations accompagnant les victimes
indique que la période où la femme se
sépare de son partenaire apparaît comme
la plus dangereuse de plus l'épisode
meurtrier n'apparaît pas de façon isolée
mais il est bien souvent précédé par de
nombreux autres actes de violence qui ne
sont pas forcément l'objet de
signalement judiciaire mais qui pourtant
devrait être prise en compte comme
autant de signaux le décès de la femme
est très souvent l'aboutissement d'un
processus de violence masculine qu'on
n'a pas su ou pas voulu écouter
souvent les femmes victimes nous
alertent sur les dangers qu'elles
courent à l'image de cette jeune femme
du valdeemarne Tania assassinée par son
ex-compagnon lors l'exercice du droit de
visite du père alors qu'il avait un
surcis avec mise à l'épreuve lui
interdisant d'approcher du domicile de
la jeune femme cet exemple nous rappelle
à tous la nécessité de meilleures
mesures de protection pour que les
femmes et leurs enfants comme une
meilleure
articulation entre la justice civile et
la justice pénale c'est justement pour
éviter ces trop nombreux drames que je
me félicite de l'inscription à l'ordre
du jour de cette proposition de loi et
que nous avons la possibilité donc de
marquer clairement la condamnation
solennelle des violences faites aux
femmes en tant qu'atteinte à la dignité
de la personne humaine mes chers
collègues à l'image des membres de la
mission spéciale de l'Assemblée
nationale c'est donc à notre tour
d'apporter des réponses concrètes et
utiles à ce problème majeur de notre
société que représentent les violence
faite aux femmes améliorer la protection
des victimes c'est déjà construire une
société plus juste et respectueuse de
tous pour en revenir au texte même
l'article 1er de la loi propose
d'améliorer la protection des victimes
de violence de toute nature et faciliter
l'accès de ces dernières au droits la
mise en place de l'ordonnance de
protection est une révolution car elle
nous fait passer de la fatalité des
enjures des coups des viols à la
responsabilité de Cha unee des personnes
ou institutions auxqueles la femme
victime demande de l'aide cela va du
dépôt de plainte à la procédure en
justice de la demande de soutien à celle
d'aide sociale pendant toute la durée de
l'ordonnance de protection c'est-à-dire
4 mois prolongeable si la la femme a
engagé une demande en divorce ou de
séparation de corps les femmes auront la
possibilité d'engager des procédures
contre leurs compagnons ou leur
ex-compagnons alors que jusqu'à présent
seul moins de 10 % d'entre elles oser
porter plainte de peur de représaill le
dispositif prévu ne s'étend pour le
moment qu'aux seules victimes de
violence conjugale et familial or c'est
bien toutes les femmes victimes de
violence ou en situation de danger que
la société doit protéger quel que soi
les motifs ou circonstances de ce danger
l'article 2 de ce texte renforce la
protection en créant un nouveau délit en
cas de violation de certaines
obligations imposées par le juge aux
affaires familiales à l'homme violent à
nouveau la société envoie alors un signe
fort aux auteurs de violence un autre
volet très attendu est celui qui
concerne les enfants vivant dans un
foyer où le père ou le beau-père est
violent avec leur mère ces enfants sont
de réelles victimes des violences dans
le couple et subissent de véritables
traumatismes c'est souvent à l'occasion
du droit de visite ça a été dit dans les
rapports précédents et d'hébergement du
père donc que les nouvelles violences
s'exercent sur leur mère de plus des
études indiquent que les HES les hommes
qui ont commis des violences contre
leurs compagnes sont dans 40 % des cas
des pères
maltraitants ainsi l'article 3 et 4
dedessine le statut de l'autorité
parentale et notamment les critères des
droits de visite et d'hébergement pour
l'auteur des violences ces articles
soulignent la nécessité de recourir aux
espaces rencontrre en matière de
violence conjugale encore trop peu
présent sur notre territoire il propose
aussi comme cela se pratique déjà en
Suède une mesure d'accompagnement de
l'enfant par une tierce personne ou une
association les violences nous
concernent toutes et tous et nous devons
faire appel au principe de solidarité
pilier fondamental de notre société
l'exercice de cette solidarité nationale
est renforcé dans les articles 5 6 et 7
qui prévoi des mesures juridiques pour
les femmes étrangères victimes de
violence et qui ont encore davantage
besoin que soit réaffirmé leur droit à
être protégé la question du logement des
femmes victimes de violence entrent dans
la loi c'est bien mais nous savons bien
que si nous voulons que cette mesure
soit réellement appliquée et évaluer il
va nous falloir être très vigilant
surtout dans le contexte actuel de
pénurie de logement la modification du
délit de dénonciation calamnieuse marque
une avancée significative de manière
générale cette loi en assurant une
meilleure protection des victimes
devrait permettre de faire reculer les
obstacles au dépôt de plainte que sont
la garde des enfants la question du
logement la régularisation du séjour
pour les femmes étrangères la menace de
plainte pour dénonciation calomnieuses
le deuxième volet peu abordé dans ce
texte est celui de la prévention des
violences nous avons besoin d'une
prévention globale afin de faire
disparaître ces comportements sexistes
qui conduisent à ces violences
sensibilisation de toute la population
et formation de tous les professionnels
en contact avec les victimes sont des
pièces maîtresses du changement de
mentalité qu'il nous faut engager mes
chers collègues permettez-moi de
regretter que cette proposition de loi
réduise à poau de chagrin la formation
des professionnels car au contraire une
formation audacieuse permettrait
d'alerter les professionnels sur le
phénomène d'aller-retour des femmes
avant de sortir de la violence sur les
effets traumatiques des violences
psychologiques et enfin sur la place des
enfants confrontés à la violence
conjugal je regrette aussi le retrait de
la création d'un observatoire national
des violences envers les femmes à
nouveau donc ce retrait au profit d'un
simple rapport car outil ambitieux et
performant un observatoire national
serait un pion stratégique et
indispensable dans la lutte contre les
violences à l'image de l'expérience du
département de saintsintenis seul
département doté d'une telle structure
dont je salue d'ailleurs la qualité et
le sérieux du travail qui a d'ailleurs
servi largement l'expertise l'article
11a prend en compte la prévention par
l'éducation pour modifier les
comportements sociaux afin que les
petites filles et les petits garçons
soient sensibilisés dès le plus jeunage
aux valeurs de respect mutuel et
d'égalité entre les deux sexes le
dernier axe de la proposition de loi est
celui de la répression des violences
intervenir sur la répression fait partie
intégrante de la prévention car elle
indique clairement le refus de ces
violences par la société et envoie un
signe fort à l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens l'article 17 relatif au
délit sanctionnant les violences
psychologiques permet le rappel par la
loi que les violences psychologiques
sont interdites réprimé et facilitera la
prise de conscience des dégâts causés
par ces propos humiliants l'isolement
les agissements dégradants mes chers
collègues vous le comprenez l'esprit que
de de cette loi est dans l'ensemble
plutôt positif toutefois on ne peut
oublier de se poser la question des
moyens financiers à dégager pour faire
appliquer la loi au moment où le
gouvernement supprime tant d'emplois
dans les services publics de la police
de l'éducation nationale où les moyens
manquent si cruellement à la justice où
les associations voient leurs
subventions réduites permettez-moi de
vous dire l'inquiétude de mon groupe
inquiétude devant parce que devant
l'ampleur des violences faites aux
femmes les traumatismes pour les
victimes les enfants le coût social pour
la société il faut dégager de manière
volontariste d'importants moyens humains
et financiers afin de prévenir
sanctionner et éradiquer ces violences
l'étude européenne Daphné et psitel déjà
cité parle d'un coût induit de 2
milliards et demi si l'on inclut les
coûts humains les soins de santé les
aides sociales les pertes de production
les frais de police et de justice
imaginez un instant cette même somme
inscrite au budget 2011 pour réellement
faire appliquer cette loi c'est donc une
question politique et sur ce point il
nous nous faut être ambitieux et
déterminé je sais que nous pouvons
compter sur la vigilance des
associations des élus des collectivités
territoriales des élus nationales sur
cell aussi des citoyens et je l'espère
tous mes chers collègues sur notre
détermination collective pour que
cessent enfin les violences faites aux
femmes avec les collègues de mon groupe
nous l'avions je l'ai dit déjà soutenu
la nécessité d'une loi cadre l'Assemblée
nationale a au cours de ses travaux
retenu donc l'idée d'un dispositif cadre
on peut qu'on peut appeler dispositif
cadre contenu dans cette PPL notre
groupe a déposé quelques amendement pour
revenir au texte de l'Assemblée
nationale ou visant à réintroduire des
dispositions qui ont été qualifiées
d'existantes par ailleurs dans le Code
civil et pénal mais que nous pensons
important de regrouper ici pour
rassembler dans un même texte tout ce
qui concerne les violences faites aux
femmes afin de faciliter l'accès au
droits des femmes victimes nous voterons
pour cette proposition de loi afin
d'envoyer un signe fort de refus à ceux
qui perpétuent cette violence et un
signe de soutien à l'ensemble des femmes
victimes un signe fort notre vote sera
donc un signe fort pour dire notre
volonté d'une société basée sur
l'égalité et le respect entre les hommes
et les femmes je vous remercie merci mon
cher collègue dans la suite de la
discussion générale la parole est pour
le groupe socialiste à Virginie cl
allez
allez monsieur le Président Madame le
Ministre chers collègues je tiens tout
d'abord à saluer et à remercier
l'obstination de nos collègues courte
Bousquet et jaoffroid et d'autres encore
avant on a parlé de Madame borveau mais
d'autres encore certain que que j'oublie
grâce auquel aujourd'hui nous examinons
ce
texte ce texte qui s'attaque à un
fléo un fléo qui a été qualifié
d'ailleurs de grande cause nationale il
y a peu par nos gouvernants beaucoup de
choses ont déjà été dites c'est un fléo
qui s s'attaque à tous les milieux à
tous les âges à toutes les conditions
mais aussi à tous les sexes aux hommes
comme aux femmes pas dans les mêmes
proportions certes mais il ne faut pas
oublier que des hommes aussi sont
victimes c'est un fléau qui se manifeste
par des violences physiques et
psychologiques on l'a dit aussi 10 % des
femmes sont concernées mais il faut pas
oublier les
enfants tous les enfants qui vivent dans
ces couples où se passent des violences
conjugales se passent des violences
familiales à huit clos sont
victimes alors bien entendu devant un
tel constat il y a une unanimité
unanimité au sein de la commission des
loi pour faire avancer cette lutte
contre ce fléo pour lever les tabous
pour en parler et pour en faire parler
pour informer et pour former tous les
moyens sont bons tous les moyens seront
toujours bons pour informer les victime
pour qu'à un moment dans leur vie le
moment où elles en ont besoin le moment
où elles sont capables de l'entendre de
le voir ell puisse saisir au vol un
numéro de téléphone elle puisse trouver
l'oreille d'un ami d'un voisin qui a été
informé qui a été alerté et qui saura
les écouter qui saura les diriger
qu'elle puisse trouver une association à
proximité une main tendue qu'elle puisse
la
saisir malgré tout malgré cette
unanimité il reste des lacunes dans le
texte qui nous est proposé il reste des
incompréhensions il reste quelques
dissensions ou quelques
désaccords et malgré tout on est tous
obligé de le reconnaître c'est un fluo
qui reste mal connu mal évolué
pourquoi je crois qu'en premier lieu il
faut se poser de la question de ce que
recouvre le terme de violence violence
au pluriel et je pense que c'est
extrêmement important de nommer ces
violences et de qualifier ces violences
les violences sont plurielles les
violences on y pense tous sont d'abord
les coups en tout cas c'est souvent la
première chose à laquelle on pense mais
les violences sont aussi des mots des
mots qui sont lâchés à petit coup à
petite touche mais toujours avec
cruauté des mots qui petit à petit
humili blesse abaisse torture et
détruis des mots qui amène celles qui
les reçoivent et ceux qui les reçoivent
à supporter l'insupportable et à tolérer
l'intolérable ces mots qui sont toujours
les préludes dans les phénomènes qu'on
qualifie de violence conjugale qui sont
toujours les préludes au coup et aux
violences
physiques pourtant même dans ces
violences qu'on appelle aujourd'hui ces
violences conjugales je voudrais qu'on
distingue vraiment deux types de
violences et c'est pas pour faire de la
sémantique je viens de parler des mots
qui tuent je pense qu'il est très
important aussi de parler des mots qui
désignent des mots qui qualifient et
aussi des mots qui guérissent et il est
primordial quand on s'attaque à un tel
sujet d'utiliser les bons mots et de
qualifier correctement les fléaux contre
lesquels on lutte au sein d'un couple il
peut y avoir un conflit le conflit peut
aboutir à de la violence
physique le conflit peut aboutir à de la
violence avec les mots on peut dans un
moment où on perd la maîtrise de soi
effectivement utiliser des mots
blessants des mots humiliants des
insultes on peut échanger des coups même
si c'est pas forcément une bonne chose
mais on est face à deux protagonistes
qui ont des chances égales il n'y a pas
réitération d'effit systématiqu et
réitération systématique de celui qui
frappe et de celui qui reçoit il n'y a
pas volonté de détruire ni de posséder à
long terme il y a un conflit il y a un
moment de
violence c'est le conflit qui peut
dégénérer à la violence et à côté de ça
il y a ces phénomènes d'emprise et
volontairement je parlerai de conflit
d'une part et d'emprise d'autre part
l'emprise est une violence par elle-même
et en elle-même et l'emprise est
caractérisée par l'asymétrie de
l'agression c'est toujours le même qui
est auteur c'est toujours le même qui
est victime l'emprise commence par les
mots par la violence psychologique et se
termine par la violence physique et
psychologique les coups plus les mots
l'emprise et caractérisé par la
réitération de l'emprise par
l'aggravation des agressions par
l'impossibilité de sortie de la relation
pour les deux protagoniste l'auteur et
la victime bref par la
torture et c'est pour ça
que quand on veut lutter contre les
conflits contre veut lutter contre
l'emprise prévention protection et et
répression ne doivent pas utiliser les
mêmes moyens ne sont pas efficaces avec
les mêmes moyens or le texte qui nous
est proposé aujourd'hui
fait malgré tout un petit peu de temps
en temps l'amalgame en tout cas ne trie
pas suffisamment entre le conflit et
entre l'emprise et ça limite les
avancées et ça limite son efficacité
pourtant des choses positives
l'ordonnance de protection oui bien sûr
c'est une avancée primordiale la mise à
l'abri est une avancée primordiale le
fait de pouvoir prendre des mesures pour
protéger la victime est une quelque
chose de primordial on mélange un petit
peu là c'est un petit peu dommage le
civil et le pénal ça rend les ch un
petit peu difficilement compréhensible
pour les victimes comme pour les
associations la nécessité de la preuve
n'est pas la même en civil et en pénal
donc on sent bien qu'on a un petit peu
des incompréhensions et la preuve n'est
pas une méfiance vis-à-vis de la victime
au contraire la preuve est une
protection ne pas oublier que quand on
est dans des phénomènes d'emprise on a
affaire souvent à des manipulateurs
pervers qui inversent la culpabilité et
contre lesquels il a lieu de se protéger
par des preuves ne pas laisser les
manipulateurs pervers se faire passer
pour pour victimes et bien identifier
les victimes et les auteurs c'est
important la reconnaissance de la
qualification des violence psychologique
est excessivement importante aussi même
s'il y a quelques réticences parce que
ce n'est pas facile à prouver et parce
qu'il y a des relaxes et qu'il est
nécessaire et indispensable à la fois
d'améliorer la confiance des victimes
dans la justice mais aussi de conforter
les auteurs dans la répression qu'ils
devront subir quand ils seront subis
donc oui il faut qualifier ces violences
psychologiques oui au jour d'aujourd'hui
ce n'est pas toujours facile néanmoins
c'est possible et ça devrait être
possible partout demain il existe des
techniques on sait que le le
comportement d'emprise est un
comportement stéréotypé il est
prévisible on sait d'avance comment va
agir l'auteur des violences à partir du
moment où on a AFF faire à un
manipulateur pervers à partir du moment
où on est dans un phénomè d'emprise il
existe des techniques pour les repérer
il faut donner des moyens au monde
médical au psychiatre ou
psychothérapeute pour être plus présent
à toutes les échelles à toutes les
chaînes les états pardon de cette chaîne
de réception des plaintes de façon à
identifier clairement et à qualifier les
violences
psychologiques la reconnaissance de
l'enfant victime et son devoir notre
devoir de protection vis-à-vis de lui
est également une excellente chose
préserver le lien à tout prix avec un
parent oui bien sûr si on est en conflit
non bien sûr si c'est un phénomène
d'emprise un parent qui exerce de
l'emprise sur autre parent ne pourra
jamais être un parent aimant et
structurant ça veut pas dire qu'il faut
couper complètement l'enfant de ce
parent-là ça veut dire qu'il faut des
lieux neutres ça veut dire qu'il faut
des intermédiaires pour que cet enfant
puisse conserver un lien avec ce parent
qui ne sera jamais aimant ni structurant
la médiation pénale oui bien sûr si
c'est un conflit non si on est sur un
phénomène d'emprise ça ne fonctionne pas
on est sur un comportement réitérative
dont on ne sort pas ce n'est pas une
médiation pénale qui changera les choses
à la limite si on n'est pas sûr de soi
contente une fois mais pas deux pas
trois j'ai reçu encore en ma permanence
il y a quelques jours une femme qui en
était à sa 3e médiation pénale sa
troisème divorcer d'un monsieur depuis 3
ans qui continue de la poursuivre ce
n'est pas normal comment ne
s'aperççoit-on pas que ça ne fonctionne
pas donc la médiation pénale oui si
conflit non si en prise l'information de
la victime oui bien sûr et le lien avec
les associations bilatérales oui bien
sûr il faut pas se contenter de donner
une liste d'association à la victime
pourquoi ne pas donner aussi à
l'association avec son accord le nom et
les coordonnées des victimes il y a deux
mains qui sont tendu elles ne se
rejoignent pas toujours parce que la
victime n'a pas forcément la force de
saisir la main qui est tendue et parce
que l'autre main qui est tendue ne sait
pas où est la victime mettons les deux
en relation dans les deux sens et aidons
les mains à se rejoindre le mécanisme
d'emprise est un mécanisme
particulièrement pervers c'est une
histoire d'amour qui tour au cauchemars
c'est une possession malsinee de l'un
par l'autre le chemin pour s'en sortir
est long à partir de au moment où on a
commencé à faire un pas il y aura des
marches en arrière des hésitations des
atermoimements il faut les accepter et
les comprendre donc oui à la formation
de la police des gendarmes des juges de
tous les intervenants et oui à
l'éducation et au respect de l'autre dès
la
maternelle il me paraît extrêmement
important là de bien redire que les
violences qui sont faites aux femmes
parce qu'elles sont des femmes
spécifiquement 100 % des victimes dans
ces cas-là sont des femmes alors que les
vieux ance conjugale 90 % des victimes
sont des femmes c'est l'honneur des
femmes que de ne pas oublier les hommes
qui sont victimes et les enfants qui
sont victimes même s'ils ne sont que 10
% c'est vraiment notre honneur à nous
les femmes que de ne pas les oublier en
conclusion ce texte présente des
avancées dans dans beaucoup de domaines
en ce qui concerne les violences
spécifiquement faites aux femmes en ce
qui concerne les violences conjugales
tant qu'on aura pas fait le tri
clairement entre le conflit et l'emprise
il restera des progrès à faire alors je
voudrais dire aussi aujourd'hui à toutes
les victimes nous vous avons entendu
nous continuerons de vous écouter nous
continuerons de travailler et pour
toutes ces raisons je voterai pour ce
texte merci mon chers
collègue la parole est à Jean-Louis
Laurin pour le groupe UMP et pour 7
minutes ou pas de problème
madame monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre
l'omniprésence de la victime nétaitelle
pas la réponse actuelle au délaissement
dont elle a fait l'objet c'est la
question que me posait un magistrat
encore
récemment et mon intervention pour
paraître paradoxale aant longue date
moi-même mener un combat contre les
violences faites aux femmes en milieu
famal intrafamilial et grâce au travail
social conduit aussi par tout un conseil
général et des
associations mais le souci de protection
de prévention et de répression qui est
affirmé par les travaux de la commission
d'évaluation de la politique de
prévention et de lutte contre la
violence faite aux femmes ce souci nous
l'avons tous fortement le rapport
d'information du 7 juillet 2009 a servi
de base aussi à la proposition de loi
qui nous concerne alors confronté
récemment dans mon territoire il y a
moins d'un mois à l'assassinat d'une
jeune femme je ne peux être indifférent
ou compllaisant donc j'affirmerai mon
soutien total à de nombreuses
prescriptions mais aussi de grandes
réserves sur ce texte qui accroit la
victimisation on peut s'interroger sur
la pertinence de la réponse pénale sur
les moyens nécessaires à la coordination
des acteurs il n'est pas certain que
nous soyons suivis par les magistrats le
texte repos posant sur une réalité
factuelle simple et réduite aussi et le
conjoint violent ou supposé l'être et le
plaignant et la victime alors mon souci
en osant ces propos est l'efficacité
judiciaire un texte aggravant la la
répression peut mener le magistrat à la
prudence liée à sa
responsabilité dans une vision sociale
nous ne pouvons pas que nous révolter
devant les violences inacceptables nos
responsabilités locales nous une
politique de prévention d'accompagnement
de protection mais la procédure proposée
ne conduit-elle pas à la destruction du
lien restant hormis pour les cas
flagrants reconnus les plus choquants
qui sont
délaissés les situations doivent être
abordées avec précaution et souci de
l'équilibre des droits le point faible
de l'ordonnance de protection c'est la
présomption de culpabilité le juge aux
affaires familiales doit se pronon au vu
d'attestation partielle il est imposé
qu'on ne peut étudier une partie sans
l'autre et par ailleurs le juge des
affaires familiales n'a pas de pouvoir
d'enquête actuellement donc nous sommes
dans une confusion entre le civil et le
pénal le rapport de la commission
spéciale y est sensible il dit la lutte
contre les violences faites aux femmes
doit constituer un des fondements de
notre pacte républicain et à ce titre
est inscrit dans la tion alors
l'ordonnance doit permettre à la victime
de se faire reconnaître comme telle ou
demander au juges de réunir des preuves
ou des témoignages de ce qui s'est passé
il prend des mesures de contrainte donc
nous sommes dans
la contradiction pardon de deux
juridictions sur le plan civil
l'ordonnance de protection de 4 mois va
permettre à certains de se prévaloir de
cette situation et le juge du fond
pourra hésiter à remettre encore les
décisions qui ont pu se faire faire sur
de mauvaises bases on ne peut négliger
la possibilité d'un demandeur
malintentionné conflit de véracité de
dénonciation alors les réponses
médico-sociales aux violences ne peuvent
qu'être partielles nous sommes
confrontés à une relation d'un sujet à
l'autre dans une vision collective nous
pourrions proposer de mieux utiliser la
loi par exemple sur la protection des
majeurs les dispositions mass par
exemple savez c'est mesure
d'accompagnement social personnalisé
relevant des conseils généraux et
réservé au au majeurs fragilisés
économiquement pourrait être une porte
d'entrée de prise en compte de notre
problème avec audace nous pourrions par
exemple soutenir la levée du secret
professionnel dans l'esprit du
signalement des enfants en danger pour
les couples vivants des situations
d'extrême danger vis-à-vis desqueles
nous nous sentons démunis pour des
questions de dénis de fut de plainte
mais en matière de secret professionnel
combien de résistance entendons-nous de
dogmatisme aussi combien d'obstacles y
a-t-il pour cette levée l'accompagnement
pourrait faire l'objet d'une approche
médico-sociale plus spécifique en
fonction des cas l'approche des
violences peut-être adaptée
effectivement il y a le cas du pervers
narcissique il s'agit d'un cauchemar
pour la victime et l'objet de tous les
dangers pour le travailleur social pour
le médecin pour le magistrat
manipulateur il peut mettre en
difficulté ses interlocuteurs et
permettre à la société d'aggraver les
souffrances de la victime les violences
croisées entre les époux complexifient
le diagnostic de situation pardon et les
décisions par contre ou ou autre
l'approche de l'alcoolique du toxicomane
violent relève d'un contexte social
économique différent avec des
possibilités de soin donc d'un éventuel
retour à l'équilibre donc la formation
des acteur comme cela a été dit
justement doit être renforcé tant au
niveau des experts que des médecins des
magistrats des travailleurs sociaux
alors la maîtrise des concepts par
exemple les violences psychiques sans
contact physique bien que décrite POS
d'important problème d'interprétation
par exemple le harcèlement moral ne peut
être appréhendé en fait une par un
questionnaire même bien adapté il doit
être défini par des comportements ceci
difficilement modélisable nécessite de
la précision dans leur définition car
ils aboutissent à des incriminations et
sans ces précautions nos propositions ne
deviennent que des pétitions de principe
nous pouvons offrir en fait ni la des
mesures ni la simplicité alors les
incantations qui relèvent en fait de
impuissance mais pour nous il n'y a ni
fatalité ni impuissance on a pu
constater de réels progrès par exemple
il faut le dire en matière d'accueil
police gendarmerie alors offrons des
réponses parlons des réalités dépassons
les affects les initiatives regroupant
des travailleurs sociaux financés par le
conseil général les villes l'État les
associations support sur des sites
urbains de police et ruraux sont des
expériences à
encourager la prise en compte d'état de
crise en urgence permet le lien avec les
services sociaux hospitaliers l'amorce
d'un accompagnement d'une position de
prévention face aux récidives madame la
ministre monsieur le Président toute
contribution ne peut-être que modeste
devant l'ampleur du phénomène et dans le
combat contre la souffrance submergé par
les bonnes intentions les réponses
peuvent elles être législatives mais pas
seulement
merci mon cher collègue la parole est à
Catherine main Deli pour le groupe Union
centriste pour 16
minutes monsieur le Président Madame la
ministre mes chers collègues le 25
novembre dernier le Premier ministre
cidé de faire de la lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes une grande
cause nationale pour l'année 2010 ce qui
témoigne de la volonté gouvernementale
de combattre un fléau inacceptable qui
touche toutes les catégories sociales
tous les âges et ce sur l'ensemble du
territoire la violence contre les femmes
regroupe des situations multiples
violence psychologique mariage forcé cou
et blessures mutilation sexuel un
phénomène cela a été rappelé tout à
l'heure aussi diversifié que complexe et
donc particulièrement difficile à
combattre le texte qui nous est présenté
aujourd'hui est l'issue de deux
propositions de loi l'une adoptée par
l'Assemblée nationale le 25 février
dernier qui visait à renforcer la
protection des victimes et la prévention
et la répression des violences faites
aux femmes fruit des travaux d'une
mission d'évaluation de la politique de
prévention et de lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes créées en
2008 dont je salue ici le travail fort
intéressant la seconde relative aux
violences au sein des couples et aux de
ces derniers sur les enfants a été
présenté par Roland courtau donc je
tiens à souligner la grande implication
au sein de notre délégation au droits
des femmes et à l'égalité des chances
entre les hommes et les femmes je tiens
également à remercier l'investissement
de Michel André notre présidente de
délégation ainsi que nos trois
rapporteurs après un bilan d'étapes de
notre législation je vous rappelle fait
il y a 2 ans à l'occasion d'une question
orale avec débat adressé alors à Valérie
lard secrétaire d'État à la solidarité à
la parité je me réjouis de voir ce sujet
revenir devant le Parlement car nous
l'avions déjà dit à l'époque si des
progrès avaient été accomplis les
chiffres restaient accablants et ils le
sont toujours je ne vais pas rappeler
tous les chiffres que vous avez énuméré
mes chers collègues mais c'est vrai
qu'ils sont têtus ce que nous savons
aussi c'est que longtemps rester dans
l'ombre les violences envers les femmes
et notamment les violences conjugales
sont mieux connu depuis quelques années
grâce à différentes enquêtes je
rappellerai l'enquête nationale sur les
violences envers les femmes réalisé en
2000 à la demande du secrétariat aux
droits des femmes qui a permis pour la
première fois de prendre véritablement
la mesure de ces violences et en
particulier les violences exercées au
sein du couple cette année plus tard
l'enquête réalisée par l'Observatoire
national de la délinquence avait recensé
4756 13 fait constatés de violences
volontaires sur femm majeur par conjoint
ou ex-conjoint en 3 ans ce nombre a
connu une augmentation de 31 % qui
s'explique bien sûr par l'amélioration
de la collecte de l'information et
l'enregistrement des actes de violence
conjugale qui n'était auparavant pas
considéré comme des délits ces enquêtes
ont suscité une prise de conscience bien
sûr qui a facilité l'adoption de la loi
du 4 avril 2006 renforçant la prévention
et la répression des violences au sein
des couples commise à l'encontre de
mineurs ce fut une étape législative
majeure qui nous appartient aujourd'hui
de renforcer rappelons aussi que le
gouvernement a lancé deux plans
successifs d'accompagnement pour venir
en aide aux femmes victimes de violence
conjugale un plan qui a couru de 2005 à
2007 intitulé 10 mesures pour
l'autonomie des femmes puis un plan
triînal entre 2008 et 2010 pour
combattre les violences faites aux
femmes lancé en novembre 2007 par notre
ex-collègue du groupe de l'Union
centriste Valérie lettard alors
secrétaire d'État chargé de la
solidarité 2 ans après le lancement de
ce plan nous pouvons constater que
celui-ci est positif puisqu'il a permis
un certain nombre d'avancé en matière de
prise en charge notamment des victimes
36 référents violences ont été mis en
place dans 32 départements la plateforme
d'écoute téléphonique du 3919 répond à
plus de 80000 appels par an enfin 12000
plac en cent d'berchement et de
réinsertion sociale sont consacrés à
l'accueil d'urgence des femmes victimes
de violence puis enfin une campagne de
communication avec des spots télévisés
qui a été réalisé pour sensibiliser le
le grand public on le voit un certain
nombre donc de moyens ont été mis en
place mais aujourd'hui il nous faut en
effet renforcer la législation la
présente proposition de loi vise donc à
mieux protéger les victimes mieux
prévenir les violences mieux punir les
auteurs de violence la création en son
article 1er d'un instrument juridique
novateur l'ordonnance de protection qui
devrait permettre d' assurer une
protection rapide efficace des femmes
victimes de violence de stabiliser
temporairement la situation juridique et
matérielle de la victime en garantissant
sa protection et en organisant
provisoirement sa séparation avec
l'auteur des violences quand on sait que
90 % des victimes n'osent pas porter
plainte parce qu'elles craignent les
conséquences possibles de cette démarche
matière de logement la garde des enfants
ou de régularité du séjour pour les
femmes étrangères nous ne pouvons que
saluer cette initiative et regretter
quelque peu la restriction apportée par
la commission des lois en supprimant la
possibilité reconnue aux associations de
saisir le juge avec l'accord de la
partie
intéressée la loi propose aussi la
création d'un dispositif de surveillance
électronique mobile applicable à titre
expérimental pendant une durée de 3 ans
si le principe semble intéressant il
s'avère que la pratique pourrait être
complexe il serait dès lors pertinent
d'obtenir un rapport parlementaire ou
gouvernemental d'ici 3 ans afin
d'étudier l'opportunit é de maintenir
voir renforcer ce système nous
souhaitons en tout cas la sécurisation
de la situation administrative des
personnes nationalité étrangère victime
de violence conjugal sur le territoire
français et les conventions qui
devraient être passé avec les bailleurs
de logement et les centres régionaux des
œuvres universitaires afin de réserver
un nombre suffisant de logements aux
personnes victimes de violence conjugale
ce sont deux facteurs de réinsertion
sociale et économique primordiaux qui
aideront les femmes à Seon àer sortir de
l'impasse j'insisterai enfin sur
l'article 17 qui crée un délis
spécifique de harcèlement psychologique
au sein du couple cette transposition du
harcèlement moral au travail adapter une
relation de couple est particulièrement
innovante malgré les inquiétudes de
certains acteurs sur les difficultés à
prouver le harcèlement et le risque
d'utilisation abusive il n'en demeure
pas moins que ce dispositif permet de
reconnaître et sanctionner la violence
dès l'apparition des premiers signes et
peut-être évit une escalade douloureuse
et dangereuse de la violence comme le
soulignait Valérie lettard alors nous
pouvons nous attaquer au derniers des
tabous la violence verbale et
psychologique dans le couple qui est la
plus ordinaire mais à l'origine de
toutes les autres n'oublions pas que ces
violences psychologiques et verbales
sont en fait la majorité des violences
conjugales cela a été rappelé 80 % des
appels au
3919 le révèle mes chers collègues euh
souvenez-vous euh du spot réalisé aussi
par Jacques odudiard à ce sujet dans ce
courtmétrage pas de sang de l'arme ou
d'assiette qui volent en éclat mais une
violence psychologique insidieuse pour
le réalisateur il n'y a pas de fatalité
en bouclage de film l'espoir est là
notre femme n'est pas abattue elle
réagit et c'est au spectateur bien sûr
d'imaginer la suite madame la secrétaire
d'État vous aez d'ailleurs au moment de
la diffusion de ce courtmétrage indiquer
être convaincu de la nécessité de
compléter le dispositif législatif
existante c'est donc chose faite
aujourd'hui et indéiablement pour notre
groupe ce texte même s'il reste
perfectible représente une véritable
avancée
législative ma collègue Anne-Marie
parillet proposera quelques
améliorations tout à l'heure en
défendant des amendements pour ma part
je voulais formuler quelques regrets
tout d'abord je regrette que le texte
soit quelque peu en retrait par rapport
au dispositifs souhaités pour que soit
renforcé la prévention il nous semble en
effet primordial que l'ensemble des
personnes appelées à prendre en charge
des victimes de violence conjugale
dispose d'une formation adaptée et
complète et puis les jeunes bien sûr
doivent être particulièrement
sensibilisés au respect de l'égalité à
l'instar de ce qui est fait en
Espagne nous pensons que la prévention
éducation doivent commencer dès le plus
jeune âge afin d'enrayer les préjugés
sexistes mais cela mes chers collègues
nécessite des moyens et sur ce point
nous regrettons que la formation
obligatoire des intervenants auprès des
femmes victimes de violence est disparu
en application de l'article
40 comme nombre de mes collègues je
trouve également regrettable que la
recommandation notre délégation au
droits des femmes et à l'égalité des
chances entre les hommes et les femmes
qui visait à modifier intitulé de ce
texte ainsi que les violences subies par
les hommes soient également reconnu et
bien que cela n'it pas été pris en
compte bien que moins nombreuses elles
existent cependant elles sont toutes
aussi traumatisantes pour les victimes
pour les hommes qui ont de grandes
difficultés à en parler trouver de
l'aide le sujet restant bien entendu
encore très à bout il y a un autre sujet
qu'à ce stade je souhaiterais évoquer
qui est l'image véhiculée des femmes
dans les médias et en particulier sur
l'internet c'est sur le web que l'on
trouve les films à très grande violence
les images les plus dégradantes
aujourd'hui faute de régulation à la
différence de la télévision ces images
qui sont autant d'incitation à la
violence touch d'ailleurs tout autant
les enfants il y a et nous avons déjà eu
l'occasion de le dire dans cet hémicycle
une véritable réflexion à voir sur la
régulation de la toile le texte présente
une première avancée puisque les
associations de défense des droits des
femmes peuvent désormais saisir le
Conseil supérieur de l'audiovisuel mais
cela reste insuffisant le 29 avril
dernier lors d'un colloque s'est tenu à
Madrid auquel j'ai participé en tant que
représentant de notre délégation au
droits des femmes j'ai insisté sur la
nécessité de nous montrer attentif à
l'image de la femme que véhiculent les
médias et internet j'ai rappelé qu'en
France la télévision classique était
régulée par une autorité indépendante le
CSA mais le contrôle des contenus de
l'Internet qui ne connaî pas les
frontières était plus que problématique
et donc devait envisager au moins à
l'échelle européenne ce qu'a approuvé la
représentante du Parlement européen qui
me citait pour exemple que sans pas
moins de 100000 sites de
pédopornographie avaient été recensés
principalement basés en dehors des
frontières de l'Union européenne mais
accessible sur son
territoire au cours de cette réunion
d'ailleurs organisée dans le cadre de la
présidence espagnole de l'Union
Européenne j'ai pu échanger avec mes
homologues sur les priorités en matière
d'égalité et plus particulièrement sur
le problème de la violence de genre
problème sur lequel Françoise labord l'a
rappelé tout à l'heure l'Espagne s'est
doté d'une législation très en pointe
nous avons abordé différents sujets qui
seraiit particulièrement intéressant de
développer à l'échelon européen tel que
la mise en œuvre d'une ordonnance de
protection européenne la création d'un
numéro de téléphone unique et gratuit à
l'échelle européenne la création d'un
observatoire européen des violences de
genre la lutte contre les violences dont
les femmes sont victimes en tant que
femmes passe on le sait par
l'établissement de la réalité du
phénomène et il y a un véritable intérêt
à disposer à l'échelle européenne
d'indicateurs officiels qui permettent
d'établir un suivi et des comparaisons
homogènes entre les pays membres je me
réjouis que l'idée de l'Observatoire et
était là adopté à l'unanimité même si
cette décision revient à rattacher cette
nouvelle responsabilité un organise déjà
existant l'Institut européen de
l'égalité chargé d'aider les
États-membres à promouvoir l'égalité
entre les hommes et les femmes dans
toutes les politiques communautaires et
les politiques nationales cet institut a
été mis en place en
2007 revenant donc au textte qui nous
occupe aujourd'hui je regrette donc que
l'article 14 ne prévoit finalement qu'un
rapport sur la création d'un
observatoire national des violences
faites aux femmes et non sa mise en
place effective comme le rappelle le
rapport d'information de notre collègue
Françoise Laborde qu'il faut aussi
féliciter pour l'excellence de son
travail sa grande implication dans ce
rapport l'Observatoire je cite
l'Observatoire de la parité entre les
hommes et les femmes fonctionne avec des
moyens extrêmement réduits tout en
produisant bien sûr des données
nombreuses pertinentes et
actualisées au terme de cette
intervention madame le ministre mes
chers collègues je voulais dire que si
la loi n'est qu'un outil
d'accompagnement et d'encadrement elle
est au demeurant un outil
nécessaire si cette année 2010 a été
déclaré grande cause nationale
de lutte contre les violences faites aux
femmes notre implication et notre
mobilisation devront se prolonger dans
les années à venir il est de notre
responsabilité collective de construire
une société plus juste où les preuves
plus fragiles seront mieux protégés on
ne peut par ailleurs oublier tous les
enfants témoins de ces situations
dramatiques on ne peut accepter qu'en
200884 personnes soi mortes sous les
coups de leurs conjoints on ne peut non
plus oublier toutes les femmes victimes
de maltraitan de discrimination de
violence et ce y compris à travers le
monde je profite d'ailleurs de cette
discussion pour attirer votre attention
mes chers collègues sur la situation
alarmante que vivent les femmes
algériennes de la ville d'assim M
saoude depuis plus d'un mois les ex les
exaction qui avaient commencé en 2001
ont repris et ce sont des crimes et des
atrocités qu'elles subissent tous les
la lutte contre les violences faites aux
femmes doit être une priorité du
gouvernement français en matière de
politique nationale mais aussi à travers
les relations internationales en tout
état de cause mes chers collègues vous
l'aurez compris nous voterons ce
texte merci mon chers collègu dans la
suite de discussion générale la parole
est à Anne-Marie Escoffier pour le
groupe
RDSE
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues j'ai suivi avec une
particulière attention les interventions
qui ont ouvert ce débat et j'ai relevé
leur extraordinaire intensité la
détermination de leurs auteurs et même
leur passion à défendre des situations
de détresse
intolérabl que pensè alors du décalage
entre la réalité et le principe
d'égalité entre les hommes et les femmes
droit fondamental reconnu depuis
1789 réaffirmé par le préambule de la
Constitution de
1946 par l'article 1er de la
1958 révisée en juillet 2008 au-delà des
préoccupations traditionnell de parité
et d'égalité auquel j'attache le plus
grand prix force et de constater qu'il y
a un domaine particulièrement sensible
qui rond avec ces préoccupations c'est
celui de ces trop nombreuses femmes
humiliées violentées voire assassinées
on estime on l'a dit à 10 % le
pourcentage des femmes françaises
victimes de violence au sein de leur
couple violence physique sexuelle ou
psychologique et le l'on ne peut ignorer
le cas de ces jeunes filles qui
subissent encore aujourd'hui sur notre
territoire des mutilations sexuelles ou
sont contraintes à des mariages forcés
l'ensemble de ces femmes violentées qui
représenteraient près de
1300000 femmes tous âges et toute
situation matrimonial confondu sont un
constat effrayant commis au sein de la
sphère privée les violences faites aux
femmes n'en concern pas moins la société
tout entière longtemps ignoré elles font
honte à notre société qualifié un peu
hativement de civilisé et Bafou notre
pacte
républicain heureusement le tabou tombe
peu à peu les efforts sont considérables
pour lutter contre ce fléau l'examen par
le Sénat de ce texte adopté à à
l'unanimité par l'Assemblée nationale y
participe bien évidemment nous avons eu
déjà il y a quelques semaines le
occasion de nous exprimer sur le sujet
des violences au sein des couples porté
par notre collègue Roland courtau dont
nous connaissons tous l'engagement au
service de la défense des droits et des
femmes et j'ai dit tout à l'heure la
passion qui avait été la vôtre pour nous
présenter ce projet l'essentiel de la
proposition de loi que nous avions alors
examiné est repris dans la proposition
de loi de nos collègues députés je tiens
d'ailleurs à saluer excellence des
travaux de la mission d'évaluation de la
politique de prévention et de lutte
contre les violences faites aux femmes
ainsi que les travaux de la commission
spéciale chargée d'examiner la
proposition de loi à l'Assemblée
nationale je ne peux cependant
m'empêcher de regretter que le Sénat
n''est pas lui aussi fait le choix de
constituer une telle commission spéciale
qui aurait permis de joindre l'ensemble
des travaux des commissions des affaires
sociales et de la délégation aux droits
des femmes néanmoins in tous ces travaux
même conduits distinctement font honneur
à la représentation nationale et je
tiens à saluer ici tout particulièrement
l'excellent rapport de ma collègue et
amie Françoise laborne au nom de la
délégation des droits des femmes je la
SA très investi au côté de ses collègues
femmes en et hommes en faveur de la
cause des femmes AZ toutes ces femmes
qui souffrent les protégés elles et
leurs enfants témoins et victimes tel
est notre devoir d'élu de la
République mais ne perdons pas de vue
que ce texte ne doit pas être une
nouvelle source de discrimination entre
les sexes il concerne toutes les
violences ayant lieu au sein des couples
y compris celles souvent méconnu mais
tout aussi honteuses dont les hommes
eux-mêmes sont victimes je me réjouis à
cet égard du nouveau titre adopté par
cette proposition de loi en commission
j'espère même que nous y ajouterons par
amendement une référence essentielle aux
enfants c'est du moins l'objet d'un
amendement que nous aurons à proposer
dans quelques moments il est grand temps
d'utiliser tous les moyens possibles
pour enfin mettre un terme à cette
inacceptable spirale de la violence il
serait utopique de penser qu'avec un
seul texte nous réglerons tous les
problèmes complexes qui composent le
sujet de la lutte contre les violences
conjugales
mais loin de nous l'idée de penser pour
autant qu'il s'agirait d'un texte de
plus nous avons entre les mains un
véritable outil outil de
prévention mieux vaut d'ailleurs
prévenir ces violences et mieux lutter
contre elles c'est dans un même élan en
faveur des victimes que tous les
clivages partisans se sont unis ce texte
a été élaboré et examiné dans une rare
harmonie à l'Assemblée nationale c'est
ce consensus que nous retrouvons
aujourd'hui sur l'ensemble des bancs de
cette Haute Assemblée nous connaissons
le chiffre dramatique qui a été répété à
plusieurs reprises d'une femme mourant
sous les coup de son conjoint tous les 2
jours et demi ce que l'on oublie souvent
de préciser c'est que moins de 9 % des
femmes victimes porteraient plainte mais
aussi qu'un homme meurt tout les 14
jours sous les cous de sa compagne ou de
son ex-compagne et qu'il serait encore c
moins nombreux que les femmes à oser
parler des des violences dont ils sont
victimes honte
pudeur peur autant de comportements qui
expliquent qu'il est difficile de
disposer de chiffres très précis la
création de l'ordonnance de protection
des victimes permettant de protéger en
urgence les conjoints partenaires de Pax
concubin ou ex en danger et la mesure
phare de ce texte cette ordonnance
interviendra avant même le dépôt de
plainte et permettra d'organiser la
protection et le relogement de la femme
ayant décider de de quitter son mari ou
conjoint violent en octroyant à la femme
cette possibilité d'être rapidement et
efficacement protégé en amont de la
plainte on l'aidera sans doute à libérer
sa parole c'est essentiel pour la suite
de la procédure et l'heureux dénouement
de ces situations dangereuses le juge
aux affaires familiales pourra entre
autres se prononcer sur l'exercice de
l'autorité parentale cela aussi est tout
à fait fondamental car c'est bien
souvent par peur d'être séparé de leurs
enfants de les voir retirer à leur foyer
pour être placé que les femmes n'osent
pas quitter un conjoint violent nous
espérons que l'ordonnance de protection
jouera un rôle de prévention qu'elle
permettra d'éviter des drames comme ceux
que notre pays a récemment connu et pas
plus tard que vendredi dernier nous
apprenions qu'une femme de 35 ans était
hospitalisée parce que brûlé vive par
son mari qu'il avait au préalable
aspergé l'essence l'essentiel est bien
que les magistrats puissent aider les
femmes victimes de violence conjugale à
trouver des solutions provisoires sur le
plan matériel en matière de logement
notamment afin qu'elles aient le temps
nécessaire pour décider de la suite à
donner à cette première étape sur le
plan civil ou sur le plan pénal en
matière de prévention de gros progrès
reste encore à faire car la prévention
passe aussi par une action plus large de
lutte contre les discrimination à
l'encontre des femmes et je me réjouis à
ce sujet que le texte comporta une
disposition renforçant les moyens de
lutte contre l'incitation à la violence
à l'égard des femmes dans les supports
audiovisuels
les médias ont trop souvent une mauvaise
influence sur la jeunesse en incitant
directement ou indirectement à adopter
des préjugés sexistes à cet égard il est
fondamental de donner de la visibilité
et de la substance aux actions de
formation dans les écoles pour les
élèves ou les enseignants portant sur
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
l'ajout de l'article 11a par l'Assemblée
nationale me semble aller dans la bonne
direction les actions de sensibilisation
aux violences au sein des couples dès
l'école primaire participeront à la
lutte contre les comportements indignes
envers les
femmes malheureusement la formation
systématique des professionnels qui
touche de près ou de loin au problèmes
des femmes victimes de violence proposé
dans le texte initial a été écarté pour
des raisons financière elle est pourtant
indispensable les associations l'appel
de leur depuis longtemps la mission
d'évaluation à l'origine de la
proposition de loi l'avait retenu et
placé dans ses priorités c'est
finalement un rapport du gouvernement
sur la mise en place d'une telle
formation spécifique qui devra être
présenté avant juin 2011 mais il est
pourtant déjà unanimement reconnu qu'une
formation approfondie et continue de ces
professionnels est indispensable de même
que la mise en rés des différents
acteurs intervenant dans la prévention
la protection et la répression des
violences
conjugales madame la ministre vous avez
annoncé que des efforts particuliers
seront faits pour améliorer le repérage
et la prise en charge des victimes
notamment en offrant systématiquement
une formation spécifique à tous les
professionnels c'est certes un premier
pas qui nous met sur la voie des
intentions mais des intentions qui
demandent à être concrétisées dans des
mesures que vous ne manquerez pas j'en
suis sûr de décliner pour être efficace
au côté des autres acteurs que sont les
travailleurs sociaux les éducateurs les
médecins et les associations la justice
elle aussi doit s'adapter nous nous
réjouissons que cette proposition de loi
répond notamment à la nécessité
d'adapter le recours à la médiation
pénale en cas de violence conjugale
depuis longtemps le recours à cette
procédure était controversé dans ces cas
désormais la loi consacre la présomption
de refus par les victimes de recours à
la médiation pénale l'efficacité de
cette procédure reposant sur l'égalité
entre les deux parties n'est pas adapté
au couple caractérisé par des relations
de domination de peur et
d'intimidation la médiation peut
s'avérer utile dans certains cas de
conflits conjugaux mais jamais dans les
cas les plus graves de violence
conjugale enfin dernier point de cette
proposition de loi que je souhaite
aborder le sanctionnant les violences
psychologiques créé à l'article 17 il
peut aussi être considéré comme une
mesure préventive à l'encontre du
conjoint en pass de devenir agresseur
physique ces violences sont insidieuses
infligé en toute impunité c'est souvent
le début de la spirale infernale de la
violence l'actualité nous montre
régulièrement que des condamnations en
amont pourraient parfois sauver des vies
on ne peut donc que se se féliciter
qu'une telle disposition a été prise
avec l'adoption de cette proposition de
loi qui a été enrichie par les deux
assemblées nous allons enfin adresser au
coupes victimes de violence conjugale un
message qu'il et elles attendaient
depuis longtemps et loin de s'en tenir
aux violences conjugales ce texte
prévoit aussi des mesures pour lutter
contre les violences dites coutumières
comme le mariage forcé ou les
mutilations sexuelles je les
je peux donc avec mes collègues du
groupe RDSE que me féliciter de ce texte
qui devrait entrer en vigueur au plus
vite en métropole et dans les
départements
d'outrem en cette année 2010 consacré à
la lutte contre les violences faites aux
femmes et qui fêtera peut-être si j'en
crois monsieur courtau le 25 novembre
prochain un premier
anniversaire merci Mones chur collègu
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est notre collègue Jacqueline
Panis rattaché UMP
merci monsieur le Président Madame le
Ministre chers collègues nous avons donc
depuis le début de ce débat entendu bon
nombre de propos et de témoignages qui
nous ont tous touché profondément alerté
par rapport à une situation que nous
connais sont certes mais pour laquelle
donc nous devons au cours de ce débat et
continuer donc demain avancer et faire
en sorte que la situation
s'améliore il est vrai que
l'Observatoire national de la
délinquence qui a été mis en place donc
en 2003 déclare que une femme tous les 2
jours et demi décède et on l'a dit aussi
un homme tous les 14 jours donc meurt
sous l'effet de la violence conjugale
ces faits divers écriront les uns sa un
drame de société dénonceront les autres
cette violence est plus insidieuse
diffuse et compliqué qu'il n'y apparaît
par les publics qu'elle affectent par le
partage des responsabilités qu'elle
induit et par les dégâts collatéraux
qu'elle engendre c'est ainsi que les
femmes victimes de violence conjugale
physique ou psychique demeure pour la
plus grande majorité d'entre elles mûé
dans le silence et parfois jusqu'à
l'irréparable en effet malgré les
services d'aide mis en place par l'État
par la collectivité ou par les
associations malgré les campagnes
d'information dénonçant ses
comportements délictueux malgré
l'indépendance financière conquise grâce
à leur accession aux activités
professionnelles moins d'un quart des
cas des CIC sont déclarés par crainte de
représail par banalisation des faits par
honte ou par
culpabilisation toutefois si l'tiel des
cas recensés sont perpétrés à
l'intérieur du couple on ne peut faire
l'impasse sur ces situations certes
mariginal des violences familiales hors
couple le père ou le grand frère impose
quelquefois des règles sur la fille ou
sur la petite sœur sans ménagement des
violences professionnelles à connotation
souv sexuelles ou sur le ellement
d'anciens conjoints qui quelquefois sont
même souvent sont accompagnés d'insultes
qui sont donc tout aussi
intolérables on ne peut non plus
s'attacher à dénoncer uniquement les
violences physiques les paroles ou
comportements humiliants les vexation
l'isolement social sont autant de
violence psychologique
destructrice un moyen de contrôle et
d'asservissement qui peut aller jusqu'à
l'altération mentale de la victime plus
difficile à cerner la cruauté mentale
doit être combattu et dénoncé avec
autant de
détermination si l'alcool la crise
économique le stress peuvent faire
peuvent fort opportunément expliquer si
ce n'est justifié ces faits il faut
surtout y voir une discrimination
sexuelle issue du passé et de la
tradition ne nous voilons pas la face
nombreux sont encore ceux qui estiment
que la force physique dont les a doté la
nature leur donne le droit d'imposer
leur dictac sur le sexe faible la force
et la terreur étant les meilleurs moyens
de montrer leur domination sur l'autre
et hiérarchiser leurs
relations cependant je veux aussi
associer à cette alarme les hommes
victimes de leur conjointe car
l'Observatoire de la délinquence le
disait il il a été recensé 37 hommes
morts sous les coups de leur conjointte
même si dans la majorité des cas ils
sétaient eux-mêmes rendus coupables de
violence sur leurs femmes la vie
conjugale n'est pas un rapport de force
entre dominant et
dominé nous ne pouvons non plus
dissocier de ces situations les tiers
victimes incidentes de ces pratiques au
premi rang desquelles on trouve bien
évidemment les enfants témoins victime
parfois et dans tous les cas influencé
pour ne pas dire traumatisé par le
contexte et les pratiques familiales
n'oublions pas que leur reproduit ce que
l'on a connu or force de constater que
pour certains et certaines quelques
brutalités sont légitimes et ne tombent
pas sous le coup de la loi d'où la
pérenisation de ces pratiques et leur
occultation il faut rompre avec ces
clichés outre les cellule d'ê dont j'ai
parlé précédemment il faut dès le plus
jeune âge instaurer une relation
d'équité entre les en enfant et faire
comprendre aux victimes que dans leur
intérêt et celui de leur entourage
aucune expression de la violence n'est
acceptable il y a incontestablement
parallèlement à des mesures répressives
une mission pédagogique à mener tant à
l'endroit des auteurs de violence que de
leurs victimes se taire c'est se mettre
en danger et mettre en péril son
entourage en formulant ses propos je
pense aux mères de famille bien
évidemment mais aussi aux hommes pour
pour qui cet aveu peut-être ressenti
comme une preuve de faiblesse
inavouable ainsi chers
collègues je voudrais avec ma collègue
Michel André remercier le président
Larcher car nous avons au cours de la
délégation évoquer ce texte que nous
attendions et il est vrai que nous
sommes très satisfaites et satisfaits
qu'il soit inscrit et que nous soyons ce
soir en train de travailler ensemble et
de trouver une issue et des solutions à
cette à ce fléau que nous dénonçons
toutes et toutes voilà merci votre
attention merci ma cher collègue dans la
suite de la discussion générale la
parole est à Yannick Baudin qui va mes
chers collègues je voudrais vous
consulter sur un point normalement je
dirais la séance doit s'arrêter vers
minuit5 mais donc nous devrions à peu
près entendre jusqu'à l'intervention de
notre collègue patri chinger il me
semble personnellement mais peut-être
partagez-vous cet avis que il serait
dommage de renvoyer la réponse du
ministre à demain soir et si vous en
étiez d'accord et si bien sûr Madame
Morano en est d'accord je vous
proposerai qu'à l'issue de la discussion
générale quit à dépasser un peu nous
écoutions la réponse de la ministre je
pense que madame la ministre en une
demi-heure ça
tiendra hein moins que ça de façon parce
que je pense que ce serait plus cohérent
et ce serait à l'image de la qualité de
ce débat alors est-ce que je peux vous
consulter sur ce point puisque je dirais
normalement nous arrê est-ce que vous
êtes d'accord sur cette hypothèse de
terminer et d'inclure la réponse de la
ministre ce soir il y a pas d'opposition
je vous en remercie Monsieur bin merci
de votre patience je vous donne la
parole pour 5
minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues il y a 5 ans
maintenant notre assemblée modifiait
l'article 22 du Code civil pour y
ajouter à propos du mariage une notion
fondamentale celle du respect entre
époux depuis la loi du 4 avril 2006
renforçant la prévention et la
répression des violences au sein du
couple ou commise à l'encontre des
mineurs le premier article du chapitre
du Code civil des droits et devoirs
respectifs des époux dispose en effet
que les époux se doivent mutuellement
respect fidélité secours et assistance
ce qui nous paraît aujourd'hui une
évidence est le fruit d'un amendement de
notre collègue Robert Badinter et d'un
travail de longue haleine de la part de
notre excellent et persévérant collègue
roland Courteau auteur de la proposition
de loi qui a conduit à la loi du 4 avril
2006 cette loi permit de grandes
avancées pour les femmes victimes de
violence ainsi qu'une prise de
conscience de l'opinion
publique ce texte a provoqué aussi une
prise de conscience des professionnels
qui sont en contact avec ces femmes même
si des insuffisances restent à dénoncer
et cela a été fait par Madame Dini par
exemple c'est cela également qui a
fortement contribué à la reconnaissance
par l'opinion publique du calvaire vécu
par les victime de violence conjugale la
loi de 2006 était une première étape
elle constitue la pierre angulaire de la
lutte contre les violences faites aux
femmes dans notre pays il nous faut
aujourd'hui passer à l'étape suivante à
la lumière de la pratique de ces 5
premières
années notre travail doit porter sur
l'amélioration des sanctions à l'égard
des auteurs de violence notamment de
violence psychologique l'amélioration de
la prévention et l'amélioration de la
protection et de l'aide aux victimes
pour ma part c'est plus particulièrement
sur la prévention que je voudrais
insister et surtout sur la notion de
respect entre homme et femme que
j'évoqué il y a un instant et qui selon
moi doit être inculqué dès le plus jeune
âge en effet mon inquiétude grandit
devant le comportement de certains
adolescents qui parce qu'ils sont des
garçons sont méprisants irrespectueux et
parfois violents vis-à-vis des filles
des actes criminels ont été commis et ce
phénomène ne semble pas regresser un
machisme affirmé s'exprime chez les
jeunes et pas uniquement dans certains
quartiers c'est pourtant dès le plus
jeune âge qu'il faut inculquer les
valeurs de respect de soi et des autres
en particulier de l'autre sexe pour
former des citoyens dignes de ce nom il
est donc essentiel de consacrer du temps
dans la classe et à tous les âges au
respect mutuel entre filles et garçons
et à la lutte contre les préjugés
sexistes cela fait partie de
l'enseignement des devoirs civiques
celui du respect des autres le rôle de
l'école est
déterminant à cet égard le texte que
nous examinons aujourd'hui met en place
des dispositifs fondamentaux la
proposition de loi faisait référence
spécifiquement aux associations de
défense des droits des femmes et
promouvant l'égalité entre les hommes et
les femmes c'est une bonne chose non
seulement parce que cela signifie enfin
une reconnaissance officielle du travail
qu'elle réalise au plus près des
familles mais également parce que nous
allons pouvoir utiliser leurs
compétences et leurs connaissances
spécifiques pour travailler efficacement
espérons que cela freine le gouvernement
dans la coupe toujours plus importante
des crédits octroyés à ces associations
malheureusement ce texte préconisait une
possibilité pour les établissements
scolaires de faire appel à ces
associations juste
pourtant cela existe déjà aujourd'hui
dans les établissements scolaires les
plus dynamiques il aurait fallu inciter
plus fortement tous les établissements à
utiliser cette ressource précieuse en
rendant leurs interventions
systématiques devant les élèves dans les
établissements scolaires et les centres
d'apprentis il est bien évident que
cette impulsion doit venir du sommet de
l'État il faut à la fois la globaliser
et formaliser les diverses initiatives
tout en laissant libre cours au
initiative locale il est temps que la
prévention des violences conjugales
prête une autre dimension toujours dans
le cadre de l'école la proposition de
mon collègue courtau concernant la mise
en place d'une séance d'information sur
le respect mutuel et l'égalité entre les
sexes et cela dès le plus jeune âge est
primordial cette mesure doit être mise
en place et faire l'objet d'un véritable
programme élaboré par le ministère cela
devrait avoir lieu dès l'école primaire
dès l'école maternelle dès l'école
primaire
cette sensibilisation et cette formation
doivent également être effectué pendant
la formation professionnelle initiale
des enseignants et pendant leur leur
formation continue pour conclure je
voudrais ajouter que nous pouvons faire
en sorte que la violence soit
marginalisée par la société qu'elle soit
mieux réprimée que les victimes soient
mieux reconnues et prise en charge et
que nos enfants et conscien que
l'égalité entre les hommes et les femmes
femme est la clé d'une société plus
juste et plus sereine merci merci mon
cher collègue dans la suite de la
discussion générale la parole est à
notre collègue Catherine trondel pour le
groupe UMP pour 11
minutes monsieur le Président Madame le
ministre mes chers collègues je tiens
tout d'abord à rappeler l'attachement de
notre majorité à la défense des femmes
contre toute forme de harcèlement ou de
violence la proposition de loi qui est
soumise à notre examen vise en ce sens à
protéger les femmes victimes de violence
au sein de leur couple et plus largement
toutes les personnes victimes directes
ou indirectes de violence notre
rapporteur François Piet fait état d'une
situation bien souvent mal connue et
dont les chiffres sont difficiles à
appréhender toutefois certaines
statistiques sont révélatrices de ce
phénomène en augmentation par exemple il
a été observé une recrute rudescence sur
les années
2004-2007 de 30 % des cas de violence
volontaire sur les femmes majeures par
un conjoint ou ex-conjoint atteignant
47500 cas et je souhaite insister sur le
fait que ce chiffre n'est que la partie
visible de l'iceberg selon
l'Observatoire national de la
délinquence le nombre de plaintes
déposées par les victimes de violence
conjugal représenterait moins de 9 % des
violences conjugales réellement subies
nous ne n pouvons tolérer mes chers
collègues Madame le Ministre que nos
concitoyens qui font l'objet d'atteinte
physique et ou morale ne soi pas protégé
et accompagné dans les meilleures
conditions possibles c'est pourquoi le
groupe UMP et moi-même nous réjouissons
qu'au fur et à mesure des années notre
doit droit soit de plus en plus
protecteur pour ces personnes que ce
soit à travers la réforme du Code pénal
de
1994 qui a prévu l'aggravation des
peines encourues lorsque les violences
commise par un conjoint
ex-conjoint la loi du 26 mai 2004 qui
donne la possibilité au juges d'évincer
le conjoint violent du domicile conjugal
en amont d'une procédure de divorce ou
encore la loi du 4 avril 2006 qui a
reconnu le viol entre époux notre
majorité a perpétuellement montré sa
volonté de renforcer les droits des
victimes de violence dans cet esprit la
proposition de loi présentée aujourd'hui
est une nouvelle avancée en effet
cherche à mieux prévenir et à mieux
déceler ces cas de violence à améliorer
l'accompagnement des victimes et enfin à
lutter contre la récidive je tiens à
souligner l'excellent travail de notre
rapporteur à l'initiative duquel notre
commission a élargi le champ
d'application des disposition qui
visaent expressément les femmes victimes
de violence le texte concerne désormais
l'ensemble des violences commises au
sein du couple que la victime soit un
homme ou une femme il s'agit ici de
prendre en compte une situation
situation ignorée mais existante celle
des hommes violentés selon
l'Observatoire national de la
délinquence 130000 hommes majeurs
auraient subi des violences infligées
par une conjointe ou une ex-conjointe
entre 2005 et 2006 l'apport majeur de la
proposition de loi repose sur
l'instauration d'une ordonnance de
protection afin d'agir dans l'urgence
cette ordonnance donne aux personnes
subissant des violences de la part de
leur actuel ou ancien conjoint congubin
ou partenaire le statut de victimes
permettant de sécuriser provisoirement
leur situation si la Commission a étendu
la protection aux hommes elle a
cependant supprimé la référence à la
famille dans le cadre de l'ordonnance de
protection ce dispositif répondant à une
situation précise il serait inadapté d'
d'y insérer les violences au sein de la
fraterie ou entre ascendant et
descendants sur proposition de notre
collègue François Pier il a été précisé
au regard des faibles moyens
inestigation dont dispose le juge aux
affaires familiales que l'ordonnance ne
peut attester des violences commises à
contrario cette ordonnance ne rendra
compte désormais que des raisons
sérieuses de la Commission de violence
et le danger auquel la victime est
exposée nous approuvons cet ajustement
laissant au juges pénal la compétence
pour établir la réalité des violences
délivré par le JAF cette ordonnance
organise toutes les mesures provisoires
pour protéger la victime il lui est dès
lors notamment possible d'interdire à la
partie défendresse de recevoir ou de
rencontrer certaines personnes de
statuer sur la résidence séparée des
épous ou encore de prononcer l'admission
à l'aide juridictionnelle de la victime
en outre la personne oui la personne
victime de violence peut éventuellement
et ce sur proposition du juge choisir
l'association habilité pour
l'accompagner pendant la procédure je
souhaite m'attarder sur certaines de ces
mesures qui ont fait l'objet
d'amélioration par notre commission
premièrement concernant l'autorité
parentale notre rapporteur a rétabli à
juste titre la rédaction actuelle du
code civile en vertu de laquelle
l'exercice du droit de visite et
d'hébergement ne peut être refusé à
l'autre parent que pour des motifs grave
nous sommes favorables à cette rédaction
plaçant au cœur de la décision l'intérêt
de l'enfant qui je le souligne est
souvent un tiers subissant indirectement
les violences il serait injuste au fin
de protéger de le prix de ses parents si
l' faet ne le justifi pas deuxièmement
notre commission s'est attachée à
respecter le principe de
proportionnalité en ce sens elle a
souhaité conditionner le placement sous
surveillance électronique mobile à titre
de mesure de sûreté à une condamnation
effective d'au moins 5 ans
d'emprisonnement et lorsqu'une expertise
médicale aura cons constaté la
dangerosité du conjoint nous nous en
félicitons notre Haute Assemblée
s'affirmant une nouvelle fois dans ce
rôle de garant des liber libertés
individuelles tout en maintenant la
cohérence de ces disposition avec notre
droit commun notre commission a facilité
le placement sous surveillance
électronique mobile en effet dans la
version du texte voté par les députés ce
placement était conditionné au respect
de la personne condamnée de la seule
interdiction qui lui a été signifiée par
le juge de paraître au domicile du
couple notre rapporteur a de manière
opportune permis que soit donnée la
possibilité à chaque fois que le juge
l'estime nécessaire par ailleurs la
juridiction de jugement pourra placer
sous suivi socio-judiciaire la personne
reconnue pour avoir proféré des menaces
contre son conjoint partenaire ou
concubin le troisième point sur lequel
je souhaite intervenir concerne le champ
de la rétention de la personne mise en
examen par les services de police et de
gendarmerie il s'agit comme l'a énoncé
notre rapporteur de limiter la mesure de
rétention auou seul cas de violence des
obligations susceptibles de présenter un
réel danger pour les victimes néanmoins
il est apparu opportun d'élargir les
possibilités de recours lorsque des
éléments laissent penser que les
obligations n'ont pas été respectées
nous ne pouvons que souscrire à cette
évolution dans la mesure où
l'inobservation n'a plus à être avéré et
que la simple présomption permet
d'assurer une meilleure protection de la
victime notre rapporteur a également
proposer un amendement afin que les
droits du prévenu soient respectés dont
notamment celui qui interdit au service
de police ou de gendarmerie d'effectuer
des investigations corporelles
internes le 4e et der la 4e et dernière
mesure provisoire sur sur laquelle je
tiens à m'exprimer concerne
l'interdiction de sortie du territoire
de l'enfant au nom de notre rapporteur
la Commission a très justement étendu
l'interdiction avec inscription au
fichiers des personnes recherchées pour
les situations de mariage forcé par
ailleurs vous avez Madame le Ministre
souhaité que soit supprimée
l'inscription
de l'interdiction sur les passeports
nous nous nous vous soutenons dans ce
choix au regard de l'inadéquation de la
mesure avec la norme mondiale fixée par
l'Organisation de l'aviation civile
internationale norme à laquelle la
France a souscrit je souhaiterais
développer un autre point essentiel de
cette proposition de loi le caractère
moral des atteintes portées à la victime
il me paraît indispensable de revenir
sur d'une part la référence aux
violences psychologiques et d'autre part
la nouvelle définition du harcèlement
moral tout d'abord s'agissant des
violences psychologiques nous adhérons à
l'avis de notre rapporteur qui par
cohérence avec la jurisprudence de la
Cour de cassation a supprimé la
précision du caractère psychologique des
contraintes en effet la rédaction
originelle aurait entraîné une
insécurité juridique alors que la Cour
de Cassation considère déjà sans ambigué
la violence comme pouvant être aussi
bien physique que psychologique ensuite
concernant la définition du harcèlement
moral nous sommes favorables à la
nouvelle rédaction établie par notre
commission ainsi l'utilisation du terme
harceler traduit directement l'intention
malveillante de l'auteur des faits
clarifiant par conséquent l'élément
moral quant à l'élément matériel il nous
est paru préférable de lier la notion de
dégradation des conditions de vie à
l'altération de la santé physique ou
mentale de la victime par ailleurs dans
un souci de proportionnalité il était
nécessaire de moduler les peines en
couru en fonction du degré d'incapacité
totale de travail de la victime enfin
concernant l'entrée en vigueur et
l'application de la loi j'évoquerai deux
amendements de cohérence adoptés par
notre commission d'une part celui de
notre rapporteur qui prend en compte les
DomTom dans l'application de la loi omis
par l'Assemblée nationale d'autre part
l'amendement du Gouvernement tenant au
report de l'entrée en vigueur de la loi
laissant ainsi au magistrat le temps
d'organiser leurs services pour une
durée pour une mise en en œuvre
efficiente de la procédure pour toutes
ces raisons le groupe UMP votera la
proposition de loi issue des travaux de
la commission des lois je vous
remercie merci chers
collègues dans la suite de discussion
générale la parole est à Nicole
bonnefoie pour le groupe socialiste pour
minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues nous abordons ici
une nouvelle étape de la lutte contre
les violences au sein des couples je
tiens dans un premier temps à saluer le
travail des membres de la mission
d'évaluation de la politique de
prévention et de lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes dont une
partie de la loi que nous examinons
aujourd'hui est une traduction je tiens
aussi à remercier l'ensemble de mes
collègues qui se sont mobilisés sur ce
texte et plus particulièrement Roland
Courau qui mène ce combat depuis
plusieurs années et dont une partie du
travail s'est matérialisé par la
première loi sur les violences
conjugales en 2006 comme chacun l'a
rappelé les violences exercées au sein
des couples sont un fléau social majeur
les données officielles dont nous
disposons à ce sujet sont alarmantes une
femme sur 10 serait victime de violence
conjugale en France l'Observatoire
national de la délinquance a évalué que
le nombre des plaintes déposées par les
victimes représentait moins de 9 % des
violences conjugales réellement subies
l'ampleur du phénomène est donc
dramatique même si nous pouvons
constater depuis quelques années qu'une
certaine prise de conscience a lieu dans
ce domaine le tabou reste néanmoins la
norme les victimes bien souvent des
femmes éprouvent de grandes difficultés
à porter plainte ou ne serait-ce qu'à
parler des violences qu'elles subissent
cette difficulté est d bien souvent à un
renversement de la culpabilité et a une
honte infondée à se manifester il
fallait donc légiférer afin que les
victimes disposent de tous les outils
possibles pour être encouragé à sortir
de leur prison tant mentale que physique
je me félicite par exemple que la notion
de violence psychologique soit enfin
reconnue par car elle représente les
tr/4 des violences recensées en France
ces manifestations peuvent être très
diverses insulte humiliation régulière
et répété harcèlement moral rapport de
nomination extrême et cetera autant de
violence dont les répercussions peuvent
être dramatiques et irrémédiables pour
celles et ceux qui les subissent
isolement social dépression et cetera
nous savons tous que ces situations sont
très difficiles et c'est pour ces
raisons que nous législateurs devons
apporter notre aide aux victimes il est
de notre rôle d'essayer de rompre la
spirale du silence qui entoure les
violences conjugales et de créer des
outils juridiques pour tenter d'enrayer
ce fléau ce texte s'inscrit en partie
dans cette voie et je m'en félicite je
tiens maintenant revenir sur une des
avancées essentielles de cette
proposition de loi à savoir la prise en
compte de l'enfant comme une personne à
partentière il est indispensable de
prendre conscience qu'ils sont eux aussi
directement victimes des violences
qu'elles soi directe ou indirecte
manifeste ou impalpable l'impact de ces
violences peut être considérable pour
l'enfant tant dans sa construction
personnelle que dans son comportement
social en effet même si certains enfants
développeront des capacités des des
capacités de résistance incroyables
d'autres en subissent les effets cette
violence affecte bien souvent la
conduite de l'enfant et peut se
manifester à la fois par des problèmes
extériorisés comme des comportements
agressifs et l'usage de la violence mais
aussi par des problèmes intériorisés
comme le repris sur soi la dépression ou
la propension à se poser en victime à
l'âge adulte comme l'a souligné le
rapport de l'ONED ces enfants exposés
ont un un moins bon fonctionnement
social et psychologique et présente un
risque de reproduire les comportements
violents que ce soit dans la position
d'auteur ou de victimes afin de limiter
ces risques il faut leur apporter une
protection au sein de la cellule
familiale tout en les sensibilisant et
les accompagnant dans leur vie de tous
les jours c'est pour cela qu'il est
indispensable que ces enfants puissent
bénéficier dès le plus jeune âge de
campagnes de prévention et de
sensibilisation au milieu scolaire dès
les bans de l'école il faut leur
inculquer des valeurs de respect et
d'égalité entre les sexes c'est
seulement ainsi que nous pourrons
prendre le mal à la racine tout en
poussant certains enfants à prendre
conscience de la nécessité de parler des
violences dont ils sont témoins ou
victimes l'école a un rôle clé à jouer
dans ce domaine afin d'éviter que
certains préjugés et comportements ne
s'ancr dès le plus jeune âge en
conclusion je tiens à dire que d'une
manière générale même s'il reste du
chemin à parcourir ce texte propose de
nombreuses avancées qu'il faut saluer et
notamment celle de réaffirmer la
primauté de l'intérêt de l'enfant en cas
de violence conjugale il n'est plus
aujourd'hui à démontrer que les
violences au sein du couple ont un ont
de multiples conséquences sur les
victimes et leurs proches il est donc
indispensable que des lois comme celles
que nous examinons aujourd'hui
traduisent concrètement ce constat en
posant un cadre juridique strict et
efficace afin de protéger les victimes
de ces violences tout en essayant
d'enrayer ce mal profond merci merci mon
cher
collègue dans la suite de la discussion
générale la parole des autres collègues
Joël garot méam pour le groupe UMP pour
minutes
bonjour monsieur le Président Madame le
ministre mes chers collègues les
propositions de lois dont nous débattons
ce soir marquent une nouvelle étape dans
l'implication croissante du législateur
en mati tire de lutte contre la violence
conjugale la loi du 4 avril 2006
renforçant la prévention et la
répression des violences au sein du
couple ou commise contre les mineurs
avait déjà commencé à lever un certain
nombre de tabou sur des actes trop
souvent marqués encore par la loi du
silence le présent débat doit permettre
d'aller plus loin notamment en tenant
compte des multiples facteurs souvent
peu visibles qui empêch les victimes de
parler de se libérer du jou de leur
agresseurs les questions de logement
d'autorité parentale ou de titre de
séjour sont loin de constituer des
enjeux annexes le législateur se doit de
les aborder dans toute leur complexité
car sinon les dispositifs de plainte
demeureront inutilisés je me réjouis
donc de l'approche transversale qui a
été retenue tant dans l'intérêt des
victimes de la violence conjugale que de
leurs enfants je voudrais saluer aussi
la manière dont les travaux
préparatoires ont su prendre acte des
évolutions de notre société en matière
de diversification des formes de
conjugalité clarifier la situation
juridique des victimes de violence dans
le cadre d'un Pax ou d'un concubinage
est essentiel de même l'attention portée
aux femmes étrangères victimes de
violence honore notre pays j'ai
d'ailleurs à ce sujet déposé un
amendement visant à permettre à ces
dernières de bénéficier d'un visa de
retour en cas de vol de leur papier
d'identité titre de séjour par leur
conjoint lors d'un voyage dans leur pays
d'origine je développerai cette question
lors de la discussion des amend et de
mis à tarde donc pas maintenant il
faudrait également veiller à ce que les
dispositions prévues par la proposition
de loi soient pleinement applicable aux
Françaises résidants à l'étranger y
compris lorsqu'elles sont binationales
laisser aux juridictions étrangères le
soin de gérer seul les problèmes de
violence auxquels elles peuvent être
confronté pourrait parfois relever de la
non assistance à personnes en danger je
pense en particulier aux pays dans
lesquels la législation en matière de
lutte contre ces violences conjugales
n'est cambrionnaire ou à ceux dont les
pouvoirs publics sont peu enclins à
s'imisser dans la vie privée des
populations
étrangères à cet égard les mesures
d'information des victimes quant à leur
droits mériteraient d'être mieux
diffusées par le biais de notre réseau
diplomatique et consulaires de nos
établissements scolaires à l'étranger de
nos centres culturels et des
associations spécialisées la formation
en matière de prévention et de prise en
charge de ces violences faites aux
femmes des professionnels susceptibles
d'intervenir auprès victimes qui avait
été écarté du texte voté à l'Assemblée
nationale mais dont la commission des
lois souligne qu'elle devrait être mise
en œuvre par voie réglementaire me
semble crucial pour les Français de
l'étranger me semble également important
que la sisine du juge aux affaires
familiales soit plus accessible à un
Français résidant hors de France de même
que le recours à l'ordonnance de
protection et aux aides qui en
découleent notamment en matière d'accès
prioritaire à un logement à un logement
pardon social en France l'article 10 de
la proposition de de loi adoptée par
l'Assemblée nationale tente à réserver
dans chaque département des logements
sociaux pour ses victimes de violence
conjugal il est indispensable que cette
aide soit également accessible à une
Française de l'étranger souhaitant
revenir en France pour fuir les
violences domestique dont elle fait
l'objet le second point qui me préoccupe
dans le débat de ce soir concerne le
droit des enfants à conserver des
relations avec leurs deux parents sauf
motif graves les décisions relatives à
l'autorité parental parental pardon sont
l'un des enjeux les plus douloureux des
séparations elles sont encore plus
délicates lorsqu'interviennent des actes
de violence à l'égard d'un conjoint et
les articles 3 et 4 de la proposition de
loi adoptée à l'Assemblée nationale
s'efforcent d'en tenir compte toutefois
il existe le risque qu'accuser un
conjoint de violence soit utilisé comme
moyen peu loyal de faire pencher la
balance en sa défaveur il importe donc
de vrai pour qu'une telle décision
s'appuie sur des élément tangibles et
non sur une simple et vague suspicion de
violence le problème est
particulièrement aigu dans les quatre
séparation de couple mixes qui
aboutissent trop souvent à une
séparation totale et définitive des
enfants d'avec l'un de leurs parents si
la création d'un délit de violence
psychologique vise à mieux appréhender
la violence conjugale la violence
caractérisant la séparation durable
entre les enfants et l'un de leurs
parents n'est pas encore véritablement
prison compte par le législateur au
contraire de la plupart des cas de
violence dont nous avons débattu ce soir
celle-ci n'affecte pas forcément plus
fréquemment des femmes que des hommes
dans certains pays n'ayant pas ratifié
la Convention de la haie je pense
notamment au Japon la justice locale
entérine souvent de telles décisions en
particulier à l'encontre du père
français l'enfant est alors coupé
durablement non seulement de l'un de ses
parents mais aussi de la langue et de la
culture française il est de la
responsabilité de nos pouvoirs publics
de mieux épauler le parent français pour
éviter que l'intérêt supérieur de
l'enfant ne soit laésés par le conflit
entre parents de nationalités
différentes dans de nombreux pays
l'absence de signature d'accession à la
convention de laaie ou de convention
bilatérale empêche de lutter
efficacement contre les déplacements
internationaux illicites d'enfant
l'article 1ier TER de la présente
proposition de loi amendé par la
commission des lois permettant aux juges
des enfants et aux juges des affaires
familiales d'interdire la sortie d'un
enfant du territoire en cas de risque
d'enlèvement constitue un progrès mais
ne résout pas les cas très complexes et
de plus en plus nombreux engendrés par
les séparations de couples mixtes
notamment lorsqu'elles interviennent
alors que la famille vit hors de France
je voudrais réitérer ici mon appel à une
plus grande implication des magistrats
de maison et à la formation de
commissions bilatéral de médiation afin
de permettre un règlement plus rapide
des centaines de dossiers toujours en
attente qui constituent à la fois des
violations intolérables des droits de
l'enfant et des violence insoutena pour
le parent privé de contact avec eux il
serait également important de renforcer
la formation en droit international de
la famille à l'École nationale de la
magistrature et de nommer dans toutes
les cours appppel un magistrat compétent
en matière de droit international de la
famille et particulièrement de
déplacements internationaux d'enfants de
demandes que j'avais déjà formulé en
2007 je conclurai en rappelant les
enjeux considérables de la lutte contre
la violence conjugale pour notre société
comment des jeunes grandissant au
contact quotidien de la violence ou
injustement privé de contact avec l'un
de leurs parents pourrai-il bâtir une
société de justice et de de paix le
foyer familial est la première source
d'apprentissage du respect de l'autre et
du principe d'égalité des sexes l'école
et la seconde il me semble essentiel de
renforcer la sensibilisation sur ces
sujets l'école comme y appelle l'article
11a cette mission est d'autant plus
cruciale pour nos établissements
scolaires à l'étranger s'ils sont
plébicités par les Français comme par
les étrangers pour l'excellence des
enseignements qu'il dispens il importe
de les encourager à mieux diffuser les
valeurs qui constituent le sole de notre
République je vous remercie merci mes
chers
collègues dans la suite de la discussion
générale la parole est à jean-jaces
Mirassou pour le groupe socialiste pour
minutes bonsoir monsieur le
Président Monsieur le
Président Madame la Ministre mes chers
collègues le constat a été fait par bien
d'autres avant moi les violences au C
des couples ont trop longtemps été tabou
et occulté et le fait qu'elles ait eu
lieu dans la sphère privée légitimer
leur passage de sous silence hors de T
violence regarde leur ampleur de leur
gravité de leurs conséquences ravageuses
sur les femmes et les enfants sont un
véritable fléo que plus personne n'a le
droit d'oublier d'ignorer et contre
lequel nous devons lutter de la manière
la plus ferme qui soit ceci au nom et
cela a été dit avant moi des valeurs de
notre pacte républicain et au nom aussi
d'une société qui se voudrait accompl là
est véritablement notre devoir de
législateur le nombre important et la
gravité des faits de violence dont les
femmes sont victimes aujourd'hui en
France est alarmant cela également est
évoqué tous les 2 jours et demi en
France une femme meurt sous les coups de
son conjoint c'est intolérable et cette
donnée témoigne de l'urgence de la
situation et justifie donc pleinement le
débat que nous menons aujourd'hui dans
le cadre d'une démarche initiée il faut
le rappeler grâce à une proposition de
loi déposée déjà par notre excellent
collègue Roland courto et qui a abouti à
la à la loi cadre du 4 avril 2006 à
l'époque c'est essentiellement le volet
répressif qui avait été renforcé et
cette initiative louable et volontariste
a permis de faire sortir de l'ombre
l'indiciible jusque-là confiné dans la
sphère privée même s'il est vrai et cela
a été remarqué par d'autres que la route
est encore longue pour faire évoluer les
mentalités c'est d'ailleurs dès leur
plus jeune âge qu'il faut sensibiliser
les enfants à l'école puis au collège et
enfin au lycée sur l'égalité entre les
hommes et les femmes sur la lutte contre
les préjugés sexistes et plus
généralement sur le respect du àterie la
loi de 2006 a entraînit une augmentation
du nombre des plaintes cependant il est
aujourd'hui notre devoir de renforcer la
législation sur les violences envers les
femmes et au sein des couples et envoyer
un signal fort à la fois aux victimes
mais également et surtout aux auteurs
des violences dans la violence conjugale
il y a les coupts mais pas seulement
cela constitue un tout cette violence
globale répond de domination qui vise à
une forme de destruction de la femme ces
souffrances ne sont pas de simple
conséquences des violences exercé elle
constitue malheureusement le but
recherché par celui qui les exerce il
faut donc affirmer clairement ici plus
qu'ailleurs que la violence n'est pas un
problème c'est un délit ça peut devenir
un crime la nouvelle proposition de loi
de Roland cour prévoit une information
et sensibilisation dans les écoles on
l'a dit mais également dans le but de
prise en compte plus global la formation
de tous les acteurs sociaux médicaux
judiciaires afin d'améliorer l'accueil
la protection et le suivi des victime la
proposition de loi quant à elle votée
par l'Assemblée nationale poursuit un
triple objectif protéger prévenir et
punir parmi les mesures innovantes il
faut citer l'ordonnance de protection
que peut délivrer en urgence le juge des
affaires familiales afin de protéger les
victimes dans de nombreux cas de figure
il est une autre innovation qui mérite
être citée celle qui crée le délit de
violence psychologique au sein des
couples calqué sur le modèle du
harcèlement moral au travail modulé en
fonction de la durée d'incapacité totale
de travail subi et de ce point de vue il
est évident que les médecins devraient
avoir un rôle déterminant dans la
détection de ce type de violence tout
aussi destructif conduisant à un
alentissement psychologique pouvant
lui-même dans le pire des cas conduire
au suicide parce que nous avons affaire
à des personnes en situation de profonde
détresse la législation justifie d'être
renforcée pour faciliter la détection
des violences l'accompagnement et la
prise en charge des victimes souignons
d'ailleurs au passage les acteurs de
terrain du monde associatif devrait
pouvoir intervenir le plus rapidement
possible en terme
d'accompagnement les violences par
ailleurs dans un couple c'est évident
affecte également les enfants et ont des
conséquences très graves sur leur vision
du couple de la famille sur leur
construction identitaire et sur l'image
qu'ils se font de la femme dans la
famille comme dans la société il est
donc important qu'au-delà de la
protection des femmes dans un couple on
puisse également protéger les enfants et
faire en sorte que la vision qui sera la
l'URE de la femme de la famille et plus
généralement de la société
soit celle que nous appelons de nos vœux
c'est-à-dire respectueuse de l'autre et
des principes
républicains nous pensons que cette
proposition de loi constitue sans
vouloir pour autant la surévaluer un
outil qui donnera les moyens à nos
concitoyens d'opérer dans un premier
temps une prise de conscience collective
qui elle-même devrait être porteuse de
l'engagement véritablement citoyen
permettant de franchir une nouvelle
étape don nous espérons par ailleurs
qu'elle interviendra grâce à cette loi
le plus rapidement
possible merci mon cher
collègue a parler notre collègue
patriciaing pour le groupe socialiste
pour 5
minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues nous examinons
aujourd'hui une proposition de loi
traitant la violence faite aux femme
cette violence pose un grave problème de
santé publique et n'est autre qu'une
violation des droits de la personne
humaine il s'agit d'un enjeu de
développement de notre société la
violence à l'encontre des femmes est
présente aussi bien au sein des couples
que sur le lieu de travail les faits
démontrent qu'il y a urgence aujourd'hui
une femme meurt tous les 2 jours et demi
dans notre pays nous devons remédier à
cette situation au plus vite pour lutter
plus efficacement contre les violences
faites aux femmes le droit international
oblige les États à sanctionner les
auteurs mais aussi à agir pour prévenir
ces violences et garantir une réparation
adéquate aux personnes qui les ont subis
mon intervention portera essentiellement
sur la prévention car elle est
essentielle le système de prévention
doit commencer au collège et au lycées
afin de sensibiliser la violence et
d'apprendre le respect de l'autre la
lutte contre les violences doit être
pensée en terme d'égalité hommes-femme
il est essentiel d'engager un plan
d'information de sensibilisation et de
formation sur les valeurs d'égalité
hommes-femm dans les établissements
scolaires un enseignement obligatoire
hebdomadaire sur les principes d'égalité
doit être engagé il faut promouvoir une
éducation à la nonvolence et au respect
des êtres humains par ailleurs c'est au
nom de cette égalité qu'il faut parler
de violence au sein du couple et non
uniquement des violences faites aux
femmes car nous devons également prendre
en contre les hommes en en effet les
hommes sont victimes eux aussi de
violence c'est une réalité dont il faut
prendre conscience d'où l'importance de
rajouter dans le titre de cette loi
violence au sein des couples et aux
incidence de ces derniers sur les
enfants car il ne faut pas oublier que
dans près de 70 pour des cas les actes
de violence se dérôlent devant les
enfants et ils subissent directement
cette violence dans 10 % des cas avec
des séquel physique et psychologique
pour mieux lutter contre les violences
au sein des couples il faut mettre en
place une information régulière de
l'opinion publique sur la problématique
des violences et de mettre en œuvre en
lien avec l'éducation nationale une
campagne de prévention des comportement
sexistes dans les milieux scolaires avec
une journée nationale d'information et
de prévention
la création de l'Observatoire national
des violences faites aux femmes
permettrait aussi de mieux connaître et
de mesurer l'ampleur et les différents
aspects de ce fléau par une collecte
systématique des données mais aussi de
surveiller la coordination des actions
mises en œuvre par ailleurs la
prévention doit s'adresser non seulement
aux victimes pour qu'elle ose briser le
mur de silence mais aussi à l'entourage
pour qu'il aide la victime quant aux
agresseurs ils doivent également prendre
conscience que la violence est un crime
la lutte contre cette violence doit
devenir une priorité et à tous les
niveaux s'il existeent des mesures et
dispositions relatives à la lutte contre
la violence et au sein du couple
celles-ci sont disparates morcelées et
appliqué de façon hétérogène sur le
territoire national il faut une
politique ambitieuse en la matière avec
de véritaable action coordonnée concerté
entre tous les acteurs policiers
gendarmes magistrats travaill sociaux
personnel médical élus doivent se
concerter et intervenir de manière
prioritaire dans ce domaine il faut
aussi renforcer la formation pour tous
ces acteurs de plus il ne faut pas
oublier le rôle des médecins qui est
très important des études montrent à cet
écart que les femmes avaient
principalement recours au médecins en
premier lieu les médecins peuvent à la
fois constater les violences et les
aider les victimes à en parler et les
orienter sur les structures d'accueil
nous devons également prendre des
mesures d'accompagnement pour les femmes
victimes de violence afin de les aider
et se reconstruire et se réinserer dans
la vie il faut donc une réponse globale
coordonnée et accompagnée de moyens
humains et financiers renforcer les
coordinations au niveau national
permettra une action efficace et un
recueil d'information aujourd'hui il est
de notre responsabilité de lutter contre
toutes les formes de discrimination et
de violence en développant une promotion
de l'égalité des femmes et des hommes il
faut changer les mentalités cette lutte
réside dans un seul mot prévention
notamment par une éducation au respect à
l'autre et une éducation pour la non
violence l'éducation doit être au cœur
d'un projet de société car elle forme
jeunes et moins jeunes aux attitudes de
dialogue et de non violence elle
transmet des valeurs de tolérance et
d'ouverture je vous remercie
merci
merci mon chers collègue dans la suite
de discussion générale la parole est à
Madame Nadine Morano secrétaire d'État
chargé de la famille et de la solidarité
madame la ministre monsieur le Président
merci mesdames et Messieurs les les
sénateurs monsieur le président de la
commission des lois monsieur le
rapporteur ce soir c'est en fait à
travers vous la Nation toute entière qui
est
mobilisée parce que une femme meurt tous
les de jours et demi dans notre
pays parce que 75000
femmes sont violé chaque année selon le
rapport 2009 de l'Office national de la
délinquence parce que les mariages
forcés sont inacceptables et concernent
près de 8000
adolesc parce que la
violence
physique mais la violence
psychologique sont
intolérables parce
que toutes ces cellules familiales qui
ont maintenant bougé nous demandent
aussi d'apporter des réponses
appropriées il n'y a pas que le mariage
il y a aussi le concubinage nous devons
adapter notre
législation à travers tous ces
chiffre inacceptabl ce sont des
prénoms de femmes qui ont perdu la
vie Jean-Marie bequel l'a dit tout à
l'heure le gouvernement a travaillé de
manière très interministérielle ensemble
sous l'autorité du Premier ministre qui
a déclaré cette année grande cause
nationale la lutte contre les violences
faites aux
femmes à travers l'excellent travail
qu'a réalisé à la fois l'Assemblée
nationale et et votre
assemblée avec également la délégation
au droits des femmes avec Madame
Laborde à travers aussi le rapport qui a
été émis pour avis de la commission
nationale avec Madame mugadini mais
aussi Monsieur Roland Courteau qui
lui-même était déjà intervenu sur ce
sujet encore une fois là je crois que ce
qui est important c'est de savoir
que le Gouvernement a souhaité que ce
texte reste une initiative
parlementaire pour lui donner toute la
force de la représentation nationale
au-delà de tout les clivage politique
parce que c'est ensemble que nous devons
lutter contre l'inacceptable dans cette
société alors vous avez souhaité élargir
ce
texte au-delà des violences spécif ement
faite aux femmes FAI aussi à l'intérieur
même du couple vous l'avez rappelé c'est
une réalité des hommes aussi sont
victimes de violence des hommes ont
perdu la vie aussi à cause de violence
alors nous avons besoin
d'agir de plusieurs manières d'abord
vous avez été nombreux à le rappeler en
terme d'information de prévention de
formation de suivi en terme aussi
d'accueil des
victimes vous avez tous rappelé à quel
point nous devions agir au 3919 le
numéro d'appel
80000 appels sont reçus annuellement 84
% de ces appels concernent des violences
psychologiques que vous allez consacrer
à travers ce texte et pour la première
fois dans notre législation ces
violences psychologiques seront
reconnues
mais au-delà de cela vous avez été
nombreux monsieur Baudin par exemple
comme d'autres intervenants on soulever
cette nécessité d'intervenir très
tôt en terme d'éducation des l'école un
amendement interviendra en ce sens du
gouvernement parce qu'il est important
c'est
vrai d'apprendre très tôt à nos enfants
de respecter les filles de respecter les
femme mais nous devons aussi toucher
toute une classe
d'âge et pour toucher toute une classe
d'âge nous allons diffuser un document
d'information au cours de la journée
préparation militaire la journée d'appel
800000 documents seront diffusés chaque
année ce livret de respect les garçons
est prêt et il devra être diffusé d'ici
les prochaines semaines si nous sommes
prêts d'ailleurs je pense même pouvoir
vous dire Queau mois de juillet nous
devrions pouvoir y
arriver l'information certes les moyens
technologiques également introduction à
travers ce texte du bracelet
électronique de surveillance des
conjoints ou des compagnons
violents et c'est vrai que c'est un
outil que j'ai vu moi-même
en Espagne et dont on peut noter les
résultats
déjà qui sont importants en Espagne de
pouvoir préserver une femme du potentiel
de la potentielle approche de d'un homme
violent de sa victime puisque le
dispositif sonne dans un périmètre de
400 m alors s'agissant de de la
formation c'est vrai que nous ne
l'introduisons pas dans dans la loi mais
qu'elle est importante muguet Dini l'a
souligné vous avez été nombreux à le
souligner je voudrais vous dire que à
travers cet article
10b un rapport avait été commandé sur
les formations spécifiques qui étaient
prévues et pour en faire le point je
vous informe j'informe c'est votre
assemblée que ce rapport me sera remis
le 30 juin prochain et que nous serons à
partir de ce moment-là en mesure de
faire le point sur ce qui aurait été mis
en place et de prévoir les amé ition
nécessaire concernant les travailleurs
sociaux un effort particulier a déjà été
fait nous savons que nous devons aller
plus loin c'est pourquoi je vais
solliciter le Conseil supérieur du
travail social sur ce sujet madame
Carine Morin de sali vous m'avez
interpellé sur les moyens notamment les
moyens de la
justice en nous disant le gouvernement
supprime des emplois et je voudrais
vraiment ramener à sa juste valeur l'URE
le budget de la justice qui a été en
hausse de plus de 3,42 % et notamment la
création de 1030 emplois supplémentaires
pour renforcer l'accès aux droits et
l'aide aux victimes je tenais à le dire
devant votre assemblée nous avons aussi
permis d'améliorer l'aide judiciaire
avec un apport de 299 millions d'euros
prévu en 2010 enfin j'ajoute que la
justice consacre 11 millions d'euros
pour aide aux victimes et que s'agissant
du secrétariat au droits des femmes donc
le numéro d'urgence 3919 c'est un peu
plus d'un million d'euros qui sont
consacrés par le ministère de la Justice
j'ajoute que j'ai signé un avenant de
150000 € pour renforcer les moyens
humains du 3919 au moment où nous
passons les campagnes d'information
télévisé parce que c'est vrai que nous
avons à ces moments-là des pics
d'infffluence téléphonique j'en profite
pour pour féliciter et remercier le
Collectif des associations qui
travaillent à nos côtés parce que c'est
aussi grâce à leur détermination que
cette grande cause nationale a pu voir
le jour que les films les spot TV qui
qui passe bon celui de Monsieur Audiard
sur la violence psychologique mais celui
qui a été diffusé le 25 novembre dernier
et qui sera diffusé plusieurs fois dans
la ané sur les chaînes
publiques
incite sur l'indifférence des violences
qui sont faites aux femmes notamment
lorsque derrière la cloison vous
entendez des violences et que le silence
intervient on peut là aussi penser que
une femme a sans doute perdu la vie de
l'autre côté de de la cloison et et que
l'indifférence et et le résultat de de
cette mort inacceptable par ailleurs
beaucoup aussi euh d'entre vous madame
Clais par exemple
ont
évoqué madame Panis aussi enfin beaucoup
d'entre vous je pense vous l'avez évoqué
euh dans dans vos interventions l'impact
sur les enfants l'impact sur les enfants
on sait très bien que les victimes
collatéral euh ce sont les enfants
s'agissant des violences euh fait aux
femmes ou les violences au sein du
couple le spot qui sera diffusé à
l'initiative du gouvernement aussi au
cours de cette année et mais justement
en scène des enfants qui reproduisent
cette ces scènes de violence et dont on
sait l'impact après sur la construction
de leur
existence s'agissant de la politique
gouvernement en faveur des espaces de
rencontres là aussi je je voulais vous
dire que le ministère de l'injustice est
intervenu puisque en 2010 contrairement
à ce que j'ai entendu Madame Catherine
Morin de C je voudrais vous dire que
nous ne baissons pas les subventions aux
associations 251 associations de
médiation familiale et d'espace de
rencontre le financement par la
Chancellerie s'élevé en 2002 pour vous
donner un ordre de grandeur à
2400914 € il s'élève en 2009 à 950 3200
€ soit qu fois plus s'agissant de des
Français de de l'étranger madame garot
MAM vous vous nous avez interpellé et je
voulais vous dire
que le projet de texte dispose déjà que
les autorités consulaires françaises
prennent les mesures adaptées pour
assurer avec leur consentement le retour
sur le territoire français des personnes
de nationalité
française qui réside
sur le territoire résidant sur le
territoire et qui serait victime de
violence nous sommes vraiment et c'est
c'est une de de votre volonté nous
sommes très sensibles à renforcer
l'information de nos postes sur ce sujet
par voie d'information de la part du qu
d'orset par ailleurs nous
militons à chaque rencontre atéral avec
les États non signataires de la
convention de lae relative au
déplacement illicite des enfants pour
les inciter à ratifier ce texte
international très efficace des
négociations sont actuellement en cours
pour permettre d'avancer en ce domaine
avec la Fédération de Russie le bureau
d'entraide civile et commerciale du
ministère de la Justice en sa qualité
d'autorité centrale constitue un
interlocuteur précieux pour favor iser
la coopération judiciaire internationale
l'inscription au fichiers des personnes
recherchées des mesure d'interdiction de
sortie du territoire des enfants prévu
par la proposition loi participe des
efforts des pouvoirs publics pour lutter
au déplacement illicite
d'enfants voilà les éléments que je
voulais vous donner par rapport aux
interventions qui ont été les vôtres ce
soir nous aurons évidemment à peaufiner
cette proposition de loi pour arriver et
et je pense que c'est l'objectif de
votre assemblée à ce que très vite ce
texte puisse voir le jour pour renforcer
notre arsenal législatif nos moyens
technologiques et du côté également du
gouvernement les moyens évidemment de
formation puisque c'est évidemment un
élément important de lutte contre les
violences et puis de sensibilisation
parce que sans information de la
population nous ne pourrons pas
mobiliser l'ensemble de la nation mais
aujourd'hui c'est tous ensemble que nous
voulons lutter contre ce qui est
inacceptable de notre pays les violences
contre les femmes et les violences au
sein du couple merci de votre
attention l'examen de cette proposition
de loi se poursuivra ce soir dans
l'hémicycle lundi le texte arrivera en
seconde lecture à l'Assemblée nationale
en vue de son adoption définitive roland
Courteau le sénateur auteur de la
proposition de loi souhaite faire du 25
novembre la journée de lutte contre les
violences au sein des couples François
Fillon le Premier ministre a déclaré la
lutte contre les violences conjugales
grande cause nationale pour l'année 2010
cet après-midi le Sénat examine une
proposition de loi sur les transactions
financières vous pourrez suivre cette
séance sur Public Sénat à partir de
16h30 très bonne
journée